GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER AT
THE HEARING ROOM IS OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING. ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE I KNOW THAT
ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
TO THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD OR REPRINTED.
EVERYONE IS ENCOURAGED TO WATCH
THE HEARING PERMITS LIVE STREAM
ON THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. YOU
CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR BY USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. WE ALLOW TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IF YOU HAVE
REGISTERED IN ADVANCE. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESS TESTIMONY AND
COMMENTS WILL BE LIMITED. TO
YOUR POSITION ONLY. WE WILL
START WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO HAVE GRACED US WITH
THEIR PRESENCE HERE IN THE ROOM.
AND THEN WE WILL MOVE AFTER THAT
TO THE TELEPHONE LINES TO USE
OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. 877-692-8950 SEVEN.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ELEVEN HUNDRED I DIDN'T
CATCH THAT DON'T WORRY YOU CAN
FIND THAT NUMBER AGAIN IN OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. AND IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
AT 916-319-2090 THREE AND OUR
STAFF WILL TRY THEIR VERY BEST
TO HELP YOU. FINALLY
UNFORTUNATELY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING
IS PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED
AND THAT WILL NOT BE PERMITTED.
EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THAT PARTICULAR BILL AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND I'LL WARN THEM THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT
IN REMOVAL FROM THE BUILDING. WE
WILL ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD
OF THE INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND
THE NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE KAT
CONDUCT. I MAY HAVE TO
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE HEARING
HOPEFULLY THAT WON'T COME TO
THAT. IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL HAVE TO REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THIS BUILDING. I THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR COOPERATION. AND
WITH THAT WE MADE BEGIN OUR
HEARING WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
AT THIS POINT SO WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH A SUB COMMITTEE AND
HERE BILLS UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE
ARE ABLE TO VOTE ON THEM.
LUCKILY FOR EVERYBODY THE AUTHOR
OF THE FIRST BILL. IS HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN. YOU ARE
WELCOME 2% WHEN YOU'RE READY.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
YOU. WE CAN HEAR YOU I THANK HIM
TO BE COMING OUT OF MY PODIUM
HERE MONDAY. OKAY THEY SAID THAT
EVEN THOUGH IT'S COMING OUT OF
MY- MY SPEAKER IT'S NOT COMING
OUT OF THE SPEAKER IN THE ROOM
SO WE'RE GONNA FIGURE THAT OUT.
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
AGAIN. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING SO DILIGENTLY ON THIS
BILL MY STAFF ON THIS BILL. AS A
RESULT WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR UPDATES EXISTING VEHICLE
CODE. BY TELLING STATUTE TO
INCLUDE SHARED MICROBIAL E.
DEVICES UNDER ITS PROTECTION.
PREDATORY TOWING PRACTICES HAVE
STIFLED A KEY ACCESS TO
MICROBREWERY AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WITH THOUSANDS
OF DEVICES. WRONGFULLY
IMPOUNDED. THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE PROPER NOTIFICATION
PROCEDURES ARE HERE TWIN DEVICES
ARE CODE. SHARE MICRO MOBILITY
IN AND PROBABLY OWN DEVICES
REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT. ECONOMY
AND LIVABILITY IN CALIFORNIA
CITIES AB TWO ONE SEVEN FOUR BY
EXTENSION HELP PROTECT THESE
BENEFITS. TODAY WE HAVE SOME
WITNESS TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. AS ANDREA QUORUM DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATIVE POLICY FOR BURKE.
THANKYOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
FIND ANDREA CORR THE WITNESS FOR
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME YES. HI KAREN
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAN FOR
OFFERING AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR MY NAME IS SANDRA CORBIN
I'M THE LAST DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE POLICY FOR BIRD. ON
BEHALF OF MICHAEL ABILITY
OPERATORS BIRD LIME AND SPIN AND
LEFT I WOULD LIKE TO STATE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR WHICH WOULD PROTECT
MICROBIOLOGY VEHICLES FROM
PREDATORY TOWING PRACTICES. I
SHARED MY GRANDMA ABILITY
PROVIDERS WE MANAGE STATUS
ACTIVE PROGRAMS THAT HELP YOU
MISTER MUNICIPALITIES ALLEVIATE
TRAFFIC AND PARKING CONGESTION
REDUCE HARMFUL EMISSIONS
STRENGTHEN THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND
ENHANCE TRANSIT ACCESS AND FIRST
LAST MILE CONNECTIVITY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE FACING A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA OF PREDATORY TOWING
COMPANIES IMPOUNDING THOUSANDS
OF VEHICLES AND HOLDING THEM
ILLEGALLY WITHOUT FOLLOWING
STATUTORY PROTOCOL. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE TOWING COMPANIES
MUST FOLLOW THE REQUIREMENTS OF
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE SECTION
TWO TWO SIX FIVE EIGHT IN ORDER
TO TELL MICHAEL MOBILITY
VEHICLES FROM PRIVATE PROPERTY.
IN OUR EXPERIENCE PREDATORY
TOWING COMPANIES WILL POINT TO
THE CALIFORNIA TELLING STATUTE
AS JUSTIFICATION FOR REMOVING
OUR VEHICLES FROM PRIVATE
PROPERTY WHILE ALSO ARGUING THAT
BECAUSE THE MICROBIOLOGY DEVICES
NOT COUNTED THE VEHICLE UNDER
THE SAME STATUTE. THE TOWING
COMPANIES DO NOT NEED TO FOLLOW
ITS PROTOCOL AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD RESOLVE THIS
LEGAL GRAY AREA. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE SYSTEMS THE
LONGHORN POUNDING MAKE MOBILITY
DEVICES FROM PUBLIC SPACE WHICH
ARE ESTABLISHED WITH AND BY OUR
CITY PARTNERS. ARE NOT AT ISSUE
HERE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT UNDER AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
TELL MY FOR MOBILITY DEVICES. WE
SIMPLY SEE CONFIRMATION THAT
WHEN THESE VEHICLES ARE TOWED
FROM PRIVATE PROPERTY THEIR CODE
ACCORDING TO THE LAW WITH THE
SAME STATUTORY PROTECTIONS AS
OTHER VEHICLES. FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR AND URGE
AND I THOUGHT THANK YOU THAT WAS
EXACTLY TWO MINUTES AND THEN YOU
ARE SETTING THAT THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR ALL FUTURE
WITNESSES IN THIS HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I WOULDN'T
IS THERE IT WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON FILE FOR
THIS BILL I WOULD SEE IF TO SEE
IF I WOULD ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM HERE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR. OF THE BILL.
SEEING THAT AND NOT OTHER IT IS
ANYONE TO TEST OF IN OFFICE. TO
THE BILL. I SEE NINE OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IT. TO THE SPELL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE KNEW
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
. Q. AND WITH THAT WE'LL GO BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
IF YOU COMMITTEE MEMBER HAS ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE
BILL. I SEE NONE OF THE I. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FALL BILL
FORWARD IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE TO
HEAR THAT SO MANY OF THE
SCOOTERS ARE BEING TOWED. AND
ABSOLUTELY AS TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
WE NEED TO CHANGE THE LAW TO
REFLECT THE FACT THAT THESE ARE
MOBILITY DEVICES AND ARE USED AS
SUCH SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THE BILL FORWARD. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY DO YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
ROGER I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. PERFECT WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL TAKE THE BILL UP
- DO WE HAVE ANOTHER OFFICE.
OKAY I KNOW THAT WE HAVE AT
LEAST ONE AUTHOR ON THE WAY SO
IF YOU'RE IN YOUR SHOT AND
YOU'RE AN AUTHOR AND
TRANSPORTATION THIS IS YOUR
GOLDEN MOMENT DOESN'T HAPPEN
VERY OFTEN IF YOU COME IN
WHOEVER GETS YOUR FIRST WILL BE
HEARD.
AGAIN FOR ALL THE STAFFERS GLUED
TO THEIR- MONITORS WATCHING THIS
HEARING IF YOU'RE MEMBER HAS
ABILITY TRANSPORTATION THIS IS
THE GOLDEN MOMENT. THEY GET HERE
BEFORE ANYONE IN ORDER THEY WILL
BE HEARD.
I SEE MR GABRIEL. MR GABRIEL IS
A HOOT. MR GABRIEL IS FIRST AND
POWER WAS A DEAD TÀI DEAD HEAT
SO WILL TAKE MR GABRIEL AND THEN
MR HOLDEN WILL GO NEXT
REGARDLESS OF WHO COMES IN WE'RE
GONNA PUNISH THEM FOR NOT BEING
HERE. OKAY WELL WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE
I GUESS TIE GOES TO THE RUNNER
HERE- THANK YOU TURN COLLEAGUES
PLEASED TODAY 2% ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO WHICH
WOULD ALLOW CREEN AMERICANS WHO
SERVED ALONG U. S. FORCES IN THE
VIETNAM WAR TO APPLY AND PAY FOR
A STATE ID OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
WITH A NEW DESIGNATION OF NON U.
S. VIETNAM VETERAN. THIS
CLASSIFICATION WOULD HONOR THE
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE THAT THEY
MADE TO HELP US FORCES DURING
pTHE VIETNAM WAR. DURING THAT WAR
THE REPUBLIC OF CREE DISPATCH
THE SECOND LARGEST NUMBER OF
COMBAT TROOPS AFTER UNITED
STATES AS AN ALLY OF THE U. S.
AND MAN MANY CONTRIBUTIONS TO
HELP THE MILITARY. AND PROTECT
OUR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY. MANY
OF THESE VETERANS HAVE MADE
THEIR WAY TO CALIFORNIA NOW KERR
OUR STATE HOME. TO BE CLEAR THEY
ARE NOT ASKING FOR BENEFITS JUST
SIMPLE RECOGNITION THAT THEY
RISKED THEIR LIVES IN SUPPORT OF
THE UNITED STATES. THE STATE OF
GEORGIA ALASKA IN CONNECTICUT
ALREADY ALLOW THESE VETERANS TO
QUALIFY FOR. SPECIAL ID'S AND
DRIVER'S LICENSE. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT IT IS
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO THE
SAME SO- HAVE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU AND
YOUR MISSUS CAN COME AND HAVE A
SEAT. I TO WITNESSES FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. OR ONE WITNESS FOR
TWO MINUTES TO RE REFER. RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU HELLO AND MEMBA
MY NAME IS KEITH ARE YOU IN I AM
VETERAN SOUL WILL BE AND- LAW I
SAW OVER THE S. SOLDIER IN THE
U. POVERTY GLOBAL ON FALSE WE TO
ALL OUR LARGEST ALL RIGHTY OVER
THE UNITED THIS THIS PORSCHE
DURING THE. VIETNAM LAW. ROUTING
MY TIME AS A SOLDIER I AM
PARTICIPATE IN THE VIETNAM WALL.
FROM. NINETEEN FIFTY NINE COOL
NINETEEN SEVEN A TOOL S. N.
ALIVE FLAWS IN THE VALUE AND
QUALITY ON MOST SO ANY THOUGHT
ON. THE UNIT HI YOU'RE- INVENTED
DIVISJON. ASSEMBLY BID BURNING
NINE GIFTED SCHOOL WOULD DO
ALLOW A PART IN AMERICA AND-
VETERANS OVER VIENNA. WELL. WHO
V. EDITORS OVER WHO IS CIVIL.
OUR STATE THE I. OR LICENSE. A
DRIVER LICENSE- AND THAT HAS- A
NON U. S. YEAH AND- VETERANS IS
A CLASSIFICATION. LAW VETERANS
TRANSPORTATION OWNER OF THE
VEHICLE TO FIVE THAT THE
ACCORDION FOURTH MAJOR WHO HAD
U. S. FORCES DURING THE VIETNAM
LAW EDISON NJ YEP YES VIEW YES
YES YES DO YOU ALSO FENDER THE
THRONE PROVIDED MESSAGE. THAT
AMERICA AND YOU TAKE OUT ALL AND
ON ALL OF THOSE WHO HI THE AUTO
OWN SIDE THAT THEN I'M
RESPECTFULLY ASK THROUGH FOR
YOUR. SUPPORT TO OVER THIS
MEADOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
IS THERE A WITNESS AND- NOT A
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NOW. TO THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO ARE
BOTH ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE-
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE FIND
THE TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES FOR
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESIDING OVER. OPERATOR DO YOU
HAVE SCOTT HOLE OR DON HARPER.
YES PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SCOTT HALL
WELL I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY TWO FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS THE LETTER DESIGNATION
OF A CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE
IS THE RESULT OF MULTIPLE YEARS
OF GROUNDWORK EDUCATION
LEGISLATION SPONSORED BY OUR
ORGANIZATION CA CDSL AND
SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA'S ACTIVE
VETERAN SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS.
THE PURPOSE FOR THE DESIGNATION
OF THE DRIVER'S LICENSE IS TO
INCENTIVIZE VETERANS TO COME AND
VISIT THEIR LOCAL CVS SO TO BE
SCREENED FOR ELIGIBILITY FOR
FEDERAL VETERANS BENEFITS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY AND TWENTY
ONE- DESPITE PANDEMIC
RESTRICTIONS WITH CYSTIC
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS IN
RECEIVING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IF YOU FEDERAL BENEFITS
PAID DIRECTLY TO THE VETERAN
ULTIMATELY BEING IN HOUSTON THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. FEDERAL VA
BENEFITS CAN BE QUITE GENEROUS
HOWEVER THE VERY COMPLICATED TO
APPLY FOR. A BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE APPLICATIONS AND
ALSO BECAUSE OF VETERANS
CIRCUMSTANCES BEING DIFFERENT I
TEACH VETERANS OUTREACH TO
VETERANS IS EXPENSIVE AND IS
LABOR INTENSIVE HITS A VALUE OF
HAVING A POPULAR BENEFIT LIKE TO
THAT OUR DESIGNATION OF THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE. WHICH DRIVES
VETERANS TO OUR OFFICES FOR
DETERMINATION OF BENEFITS AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO WOULD
GREATLY MODEL THE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM BY INTRODUCING DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS. OF VETERANS OF
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE PROGRAM.
NUMBER TO STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES WHO OFFER BENEFITS FOR
QUALIFIED US VETERANS DEPEND ON
THE VETERAN DESIGNATION TO
DETERMINE QUALIFICATION. THIS
BILL WOULD DIMINISH THE UTILITY
OF THAT DESIGNATION AND LEAD TO
A CONFUSION AND HESITANCY TO USE
IT. THREE EIGHTY TWENTY NINE
FIFTY TWO IT ALSO CONSIDERS THE
PUBLIC VETR DESIGNATION ON THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE ALLOWS VETERANS
WHO SERVED IN THIS NATION'S
MILITARY. AWAITED PROBABLY
INDICATE THEIR SERVICE ALSO MANY
BUSINESSES EXTEND DISCOUNTS TO
VETERANS. AND ADDING ANOTHER
CLASSIFICATION OF VETERAN WOULD
CONFUSE BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES
AND MAY EVEN RESULT IN THE
CURTAILMENT OF SOME OF THESE
DISCOUNTS. IT FOR DURING OUR
MULTI YEAR EFFORT- TO GIVE
VETERAN PLACED ON THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE WE FACED RECURRING
HURDLES- FROM CONCERNS- WITH
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
REGARDING THE INCLUSION OF TOO
MUCH INFORMATION ON A LICENSE.
DMV HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF ROOM ON THE LICENSE TO
FIT THE DESIGNATION. AND ALSO
THE REAL ID ACT HAS ITS OWN
LIMITATIONS ON WHAT COULD BE ON
A LICENSE- WE HAD ISSUES GETTING
SEVEN LETTERS INSERTED ON THE
LICENSE I'M NOT SURE. HUDDLED
DMV WOULD AGREE TO PUTTING
TWENTY TWO CHARACTERS ON TO A
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND SO IN
CLOSING. VETERANS OF ALLIED
MILITARIES THAT ASSISTED OUR
NATION AND ALL OF OUR NATION'S
ONES ARE INDEED I NEED YOU TO A
PRIVATE. READY. TO AND THIS TEAM
I AM SAID UP THEIR YOU MA'AM.
HOW THE FACT REMAINS ARE NOT YOU
S. MILLER JET IN THE- PROPOSED
BY EIGHTY TWO NINETY SIX TWO
DOES NOT PICK WAY TO RECOGNIZE
THEM THE SATURDAY. OKAY LICENSE
I CARD WITH OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OF. OUR NEXT DIE HARPER.
MISTER HARPER I PLEASED TO MEET
YOUR PHONE LINE. HELLO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MISTER HARPER. THANK YOU
. A GOOD AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DON HARPER AYE AND THE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATION
COMMISSION WITH AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ON
RECORD OPPOSING AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY TWO. WE WERE PART OF THE
COALITION THAT HELPED WITH THE
VETERANS DESIGNATION ON THE
LICENSE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. ANY
OTHER VETERANS FOUND IN TERMS TO
THE LICENSE WILL CONFUSE THE
PUBLIC AND GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
THAT USE THAT DESIGNATION TO
CONFER. BENEFITS TO VETERANS. AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY TO SPEAK TO
HAVE THEM BE A CALVET WORK
TOGETHER TO ESTABLISH A
ELIGIBILITY OF NON US VETERAN
APPLICANTS FOR THE PROPOSED
DESIGNATION. THIS WILL NOT WORK
EITHER DEAR BE NO CALIPHATE HAVE
THE LANGUAGE SKILLED MANPOWER OR
KNOWLEDGE. OKAY MORE MILITARY.
IF YOU'RE NOT BETTER MYSELF ONE
FIVE ONE START THEIR DEGREE
VETERANS THE CREAMERY VS SO I
HAVE TOTALLY. BEFORE THE GREAT
READ IT THAT THEY GET WHEN THEY
SURE TO GET HOWEVER IF NOTHING
TO READ YOU CUT TO. VETERANS
DOES ON THE LINE FIRST AND
FOREMOST A TOOL TO CONNECT US
BETTER TO THEIR FEDERAL BENEFITS
BY ADDING NON BUREAUCRATIC
VIETNAM BETTER LANGUAGE TO THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE WOULD BE
CONFUSING FOR ALL. PARTIES HE
DID AGAIN VETERAN DESIGNATE ON
THE DRUGGIST IS REALLY AND
REGION TOOL. TO ASSIST US VERY
ONLY GOOD PAINTER BETTER. THERE
ARE NO BA OR OR BETTER OF ARMY
HOW DOES HELP THEM. WHAT ABOUT
YOUR OTHER FOR MILITARY GROUPS
THAT. IT STARTED TO GET NOW MUST
TODAY. HI TOLD ARE VIETNAMESE
THIS COULD BE A COULD BE SLOW
LOUDLY HAVING TO THEM READY TO
GROW LIKE WELL. THIS BILL YET
COMPLETE VEHICLE FORM A KOREAN
WAR YEARS MAYBE DISCARDED WITH
PUBLIC RECORD FROM THE LEAD.
HONORING THEIR GREAT MOVIE FOR A
RED FROM THE GOVERNOR THE BREAK
WE AND I HAD IN VIETNAM. I SPEAK
FROM COVERING THEY WERE IN.
THEIR BRICK WE NOT IN QUESTION
HERE AND THEY SHOULD RECKONED
FOR THE YEAR BUT MAYBE IT NON.
BILL DOES NOT TOOK DE SAC GOAL
OF THE CURRENT AMERICAN DEPART.
OPPOSES TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEITH OAK PARK. I
SUPPOSED TO DISAPPEAR THANK YOU. MY NAME IS THE SONG LONELY. I. SUPPORT FOR THIS VEHICLE
THANKS FOR. MY NAME IS CHARLES
GAME. I SUPPORT DISAPPEAR THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SO TENURE DOWN. I
SUPPORT DISAPPEARED THANK YOU.
VENTURE MEMBERS LIKE MONACAN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
SINCE YOU ASKED OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE COUNCIL IS A TO HAS
SERVED TWO TOURS IN. THE DESERT
AND I'M A VIETNAM VETERAN AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON DATA NICKEL WITH READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMVETS DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER VETERANS COUNCIL
AN UMBRELLA GROUP OF TWENTY TWO
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY TWO THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT I'M SURE WE
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. JUST A
MOMENT.
I'M GONNA GO TO LINE OF THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN NAME IS JACK
MURPHY FROM MONTEREY I AM A LIFE
pFOREIGN WARS AND DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS I'M A MEMBER
OF THE IRAQ AFGHANISTAN VETERANS
OF AMERICA. AND A MEMBER OF THE
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA I'M ALSO FORTUNATE TO
SERVE AT THE COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICES REPRESENTATIVE FOR BOTH
MONTEREY AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
I OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY NINE FIFTY
TWO. NOW GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX.
HELLO CAN EVERYBODY HEAR ME YES
. MY NAME IS LARRY DO YOU RAINY
JUNIOR I AM THE DISTRICT SEVEN
COMMANDER IN VENTURA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND VFW POST TEN
THOUSAND FORTY NINE MEMBERS
JAMIE VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS AB TWO TWO
NINE FIVE TWO BILL. THAT'S IT
MADAM CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY NOW TO SEE IF ANY OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO NO
OKAY I WILL NOT MAKE MY
COMMENTS- AND THEN ASK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE- I. WE MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S DESIRE
TO HONOR- THIS PARTICULAR CLASS
OF VETERANS. I AM WILLING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY TO ALLOW
YOU TO MOVE IT ON TO THE NEXT-
HEARING HOWEVER. I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO TRY TO FIND
A WAY THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE THIS
PARTICULAR LICENSE DESIGNATION
AND ALL LINE MY CONCERNS WITH
THAT OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. AS WELL INTENTIONED
AS THIS EFFORT IS I BELIEVE THAT
IT WILL CAUSE CONFUSION AND
POSSIBLY AT THE- EXPENSE OF SOME
OF OUR VETERANS AND THAT
CONCERNS ME GREATLY AND I'LL
RESERVE MY WROTE MY RIGHT TO
POSSIBLY CHANGE MY VOTE TO A
LATER ON WHEN I SIT ON THE FLOOR
BUT I. DEFINITELY APPRECIATE WE
ARE TRYING TO DO AND I COMMEND
YOU FOR TAKING WHICH KIND OF A
TOUGH ISSUE ON- IN THE ATTEMPT
TO HONOR A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
DEFINITELY. IS DESERVING OF
HONOR WITHOUT IT BUT YOU TO
CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK
THE WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT AND WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAY- AND WHAT TO DO CERTAINLY
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS TO HEART. YOU
KNOW WE ARE VERY MUCH COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION- I THINK
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL THAT AND HOW IT
OPERATED AND OBLIGATIONS THAT IT
MIGHT IMPOSE ON FOLKS WHICH-
WHICH WE CERTAINLY WANT HELP TO
CLARIFY- BUT WOULD DEFINITELY
WHAT WE'LL CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION I GUESS I'M A
LITTLE BIT MORE BULLISH. ON THE
ABILITY OF. THE DMV TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS AND ALSO TO DO
IT IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
DIMINISH- ARE VETERANS YOU KNOW
I NOTE THAT THE STATE OF GEORGIA
ALASKA CONNECTICUT HAVE ALREADY
FIGURED OUT. HOW TO DO THIS- AND
THOSE ARE STATES WITH VERY
STRONG TRADITIONS OF HONORING
OUR UNITED STATES MILITARY
VETERANS YOU KNOW I HAVE TO- YOU
KNOW HESITATE TO THINK THAT
GEORGE R. ALASKA CONNECTICUT
WOUD HAVE DONE ANYTHING THAT
WOULD DIMINISH. THE ABILITY OF
U. U. S. VETERANS TO ACCESS
BENEFITS SO WE WILL FIND A WAY
TO THREAD THE NEEDLE. YOU KNOW
WE WILL WORK WITH WE WILL WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION I THINK
THERE'S SOME THINGS WE CAN DO
TO. ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS BUT
CERTAINLY. APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. AND YOU KNOW WE HAD A
VERY MOVING. I'M HEARING IN THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE WHEN
WE DISCUSS THIS BILL AND- OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
HE'S A VIETNAM VETERAN ASK TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS HAS TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR SOME REMEMBER RAMOS
THAT'S ABOUT AS A CO AUTHOR SO.
I'M YOU KNOW I THINK EVERYONE
AGREES THIS IS A CLASS OF FOLKS
WHO ARE NOW U. S. CITIZENS ARE
DEFINITELY DESERVING OF
RECOGNITION. THEY'RE NOT SEEKING
BENEFITS THEY'RE NOT SEEKING
MONEY THEY SIMPLY WANT
RECOGNITION OF. THE RISKS AND
THE COULD THEN THE SACRIFICES
THAT THEY MADE AND SO WE'RE
HOPING TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THAT
SO COMMITTED TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT- AND WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
TAKE THE BILL UP ON WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS PRESENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO MR HOLDEN. FOUR AB. TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- TODAY I
AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THE BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE PEACE OFFICERS
MAKING A TRAFFIC OR PEDESTRIAN
STOP THE STATE THE REASON FOR
QUESTIONS UNLESS THE OFFICE THE
REASON WE BELIEVES THAT
WITHHOLDING THE REASON FOR THE
STOP IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
LIFE. PROP OR PROPERTY FROM
IMMINENT HARM. MEMBERS FOR
NEARLY A YEAR MY OFFICES WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT POST
VARIOUS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
. AND TO PUT FORWARD THOUGHT FOR
LEGISLATION SURROUNDING TRAFFIC
AND PEDESTRIAN STOPS. OVER THE
PAST YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS ENDEAVOR PORTS
SURROUNDING TRAFFIC STOPS TO
INCLUDE IN INCLUDE
INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE NEW YORK
TIMES IN LA TIMES IN A REPORT
FROM THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE. THE COMMON THEME
SURROUNDING THESE REPORTS IS
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR. PEOPLE OF
COLOR MORE SO FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
STOPPED THAN WHITE INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT IS MORE TROUBLING IS THAT
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE STOPS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE THREE TIMES. MORE
LIKELY TO INVOLVE A WEAPON THEN
STOPS OF WHITE INDIVIDUALS. WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. AND
POST AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE REQUIRES A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER TO DOCUMENT THE REASON
FOR THE STOP ON CITATION- POLICE
REPORT RESULTING FROM THE STOP.
IN TERMS OF EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE DMV TO
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE DUTY OF A POLICE OFFICER TO
STATE THE REASON. FOR THE STOP
IN THE DMV HANDBOOK AT THE
EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY. AS YOU MAY
RECALL THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
AND GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED MY
BILL AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH NOW
REQUIRES A DMV. TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION REGARDING A PERSON
CIVIL RIGHTS. DURING A STOP.
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO FILE A
COMPLAINT AGAINST A PEACE
OFFICER. FINALLY THIS BILL MAKES
FAILURE TO STATE THE REASON FOR
THE STOP GROUNDS FOR A STATUTORY
MOTION TO SUPPRESS SUPPRESS. I'M
AWARE THAT THIS PARTICULAR
PROVISION OF THE BILL IS CAUSING
HEARTBURN FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PLEDGE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO
SEE IF WE CAN FIND AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY. THE WHOLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR FAILURE TO DISCLOSE THE
REASON OF THE STOP. IN CLOSING
MEMBERS AS I MENTIONED BEFORE I
BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
CONFRONTATION BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE PUBLIC BEGINS
BECAUSE PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
BEING ASKED TO SURRENDER THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHY THEY WERE BEING STOPPED. BUT
THEY ARE FORCED TO COMPLY.
SURELY THIS BODY CAN FIND A
SOLUTION TO THIS DILEMMA. THIS
BILL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I MIGHT ADD ALSO
AS I AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THAT
WE WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE
FULLNESS OF THE BILL. BUT WE
KNOW THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
FOCUSED ON THAT PART THE DEALS
WITH THE DMV. ARE UPDATING UNDER
THE REASON FOR THE STOP- BUT
WE'VE HAVE IT PERFECTLY VETTED
IN PUBLIC SAFETY ON THE OTHER
ISSUES AND AS I'VE- INDICATED
WILL PREPARE TO. CONTINUE TO
WORK TO FIND A- REASONABLE
SOLUTION TO. OF THE OTHER ITEMS
THAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT. TO
ADDRESS AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND YOU HAVE A WITNESS HERE IN
PERSON I DO. LET'S SEE SO IN A
PRIOR. HE'S ON THE PHONE LINE
OKAY FINANCES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE OF THE END OF LAST
WEEK OKAY THANK YOU. I'M
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND
MISS PRIOR FOR US. I AM HERE.
THEY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF PRESIDENT RICK
CALENDAR AND THE CALIFORNIA
HAWAII STATE CONFERENCE OF THE
NAACP REPRESENTING FIFTY SEVEN
BRANCHES IN TWENTY THREE MINUTES
STATEWIDE I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN. WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE A PEACE OFFICER TO STATE
THE REASON FOR IN STOCK UNLESS
THE OFFICER REASONABLY BELIEVES.
THAT WITHHOLDING THE INFORMATION
FOR THE STOP AS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE LIFE OR PROPERTY
FROM A MINUTE THREATS-
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
OPERATIONALLY DISPROPORTIONATE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE THAN TWICE
AS LIKELY TO BE STOPPED. SEARCH
AND SEARCH AS WHITE CALIFORNIANS
AT THE RATE OF ABOUT 20% 38% OF
ALL STOPS. I'M MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT BE STOPPED THE CONFRONTATION
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND BEGIN WHEN PEOPLE
OF COLOR ARE NOT AFFORDED THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING WHY THEY
ARE PULLED OVER OR STOPPED FROM
CONTINUING THEIR WALK WHEN
THEY'RE DR- I HAVE A PERSONAL
STORY OF BEING PULLED OVER. I
WAS ON MY WAY TO CHURCH WITH MY
TWO TEENAGE SONS DRIVING DOWN
TRAVIS BOULEVARD I WAS DRIVING%
AT THE SPEED OF TRAFFIC IT WAS
PULLED OVER. I IMMEDIATELY
CALLED INTO THE SLOW LANE A SLOW
DOWN TO ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILES
PER HOUR AND BECAUSE THERE WAS
AN EMBANKMENT I DID NOT BILL I
COULD SAFELY PULL OFF THE ROAD
SO I DROVE TO THE NEXT EXIT.
WHEN THE OFFICER CAME OVER TO
THE CAR I ASKED WHY HE PULLED ME
OVER AND HE ASKED ME WHY I
DIDN'T PULL OVER IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE WHEN SOMEONE. WANTS FROM
THEM THEY LIKELY HAVE GUNS AND
DRUGS IN THE CAR HE THEN ASKED
ME FOR MY I. D. AND THE KIDS I'D
BE AND IT WAS NOT UNTIL HE CAME
BACK THAT HE TOLD ME I WAS
SPEEDING AND HE WAS GIVEN ME A
TICKET. THIS OFFICERS BIAS
UNFORTUNATELY SEEMS TO BE THE.
NORM WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR- I DON'T DRUG. I DON'T OWN A
GUN. MY KIDS ARE NOT IN GAINES
ORPHALI WITH GANGS. I BELIEVE HE
MAY HAVE CLOCKED SOMEONE ELSE
BUT BECAUSE I. THE LESS. I WOULD
ARGUE THE- AND I WAS IF YOU
WITHOUT. BEING BILL- AND QUAL.
DATA SHOW LONG. ACROSS THE STATE
AND COUNTRY MISUSED POWER. MOST
FREQUENTLY DURING. STOPS TO FISH
WERE IN. OR SUSPECT CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY WHICH PERPETUATE THE
MISTRUST IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
LEAD TO UNNECESSARY FATALITIES.
SO FOR THIS REASON WATER CLEAN
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE ARE TO
THE COMMUTE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE I ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. TO STOP RACIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE STOPS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON FILE WAS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AS A
PRIMARY WITNESS. OKAY SO IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN- IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
SPEAK IN A- OF TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. OKAY SINAN
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL PHONE LINES THAT HAVE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
JUST A MOMENT. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH IN LINE. FORTY THREE.
HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN GO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA USED TO BE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN THREE THANK
YOU. LINE. SIXTY SIX. HELLO
COMMITTEE JEFFRIES BECAUSE THEN
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT
THE A PUT A VERY STRONG ARE NOT
ON OUR FLOOR NIGHTSTAND IS
DROPPED FOR THIS A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
WINE. FIFTY SIX. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY PAIR THERE REGIS
SAYS IT'S ON BEHALF OF HORROR
AFTER WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSITION BUT- WHAT WE ARE
DEFINITELY GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
AMENDMENTS HE SPOKE OF EARLIER.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING-
AFTERNOON RATHER MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE- TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE DEAR LUCIEN HERE
CALLING IN IN OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE AS WELL AS THE
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OF
SAN DIEGO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR- ON THE EVIDENCE
SUPPRESSION PROVISIONS. THERE
WAS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYONE
HAS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. MR HOLDEN IRA APPRECIATE
THE BILL IN RESPECT TO YOUR-
YOUR- AUTHORSHIP OF THE BILL
COULD YOU HIGHLIGHT AGAIN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
CONTEMPLATING OR THE GENERAL
SUBJECT AREA AND I APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T QUITE CATCH IT I WAS
READING SOMETHING WHEN YOU
MENTION THAT. OF THE AREA THAT
WE'VE MADE THE COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT WAS RATHER
JURISDICTION AROUND THE- ISSUE
AROUND SUPPRESSING- MOTION TO
SUPPRESS WE'VE GIVEN OUR
INDICATION STRONG INDICATION
HAVE CONTINUED SINCE THE
COMMITTEE. TO REACH OUT AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS COMMITTEE I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT WE WOULD BE WRITING IT'S
NOT. GERMANE TO THIS COMMITTEE
BUT IT IS FOR THE FOR THE FOR
THE FULLNESS OF WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN THIS BILL AND
FOR YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
WE'RE HOW WE'RE WORKING THROUGH
IT. I WANTED TO MAKE SURE I. LET
EVERYONE KNOW FOR THE RECORD
THAT WE WERE GOING TO MAKE THOSE
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE. MR
HOLDEN I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORKING WITH A TO ADDRESS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CONCERNS I AM ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SUPPRESSION
ELEMENT OF THIS IN ONE MAKE SURE
ALSO THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR CERTAIN
TYPES OF STOPS THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE BUT I THINK THAT YOU OF-
ABSOLUTELY IDENTIFIED A REAL
PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE THAT
SAW ON JUSTIN SOMETHING THAT IS
LONG OVERDUE ADDRESSING. AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
VEHICLE TO GET US THERE SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL
TAKE ROLE. THANK YOU AND WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THE ONLY THING I
WILL SAY IS THAT I I'D
APPRECIATE THAT AND- NOT TO GET
LOST IN THE PRESENTATION BUT C.
H. P. WAS VERY MUCH A PART. OF
HELPING ARCHITECT THIS BILL AS
WELL AS POSTOAK- WE ARE CONTINUE
TO. MAKE OUR WAY DOWN THE ROAD
TO GET FULL HARMONY BEHIND IT
BUT I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WHEN A REQUIREMENT. TO
DO SO. THANK YOU ALSO JUST
REMIND THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
JURISDICTION IS THE DMB PORTION
OF THE BILL AND THE BILL STILL
WILL GO THROUGH THE- OF THE
POLICY. THAT DOES DEAL WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUES- NEXT.
THANKS AGAIN. MISTER BLOOM THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT. WELCOME.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. I SET UP
THEIR ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT THE
BUTTON AS THE LEFT OF THE
LECTERN. AB AND DEATH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I APPRECIATE- YOU'RE
WORKING WITH ME MADAM CHAIR ON
ALTERNATIVE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
BEFORE THE MEMBERS TODAY AND
I'LL BE ACCEPTING- THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BEEN SHARED.
THE- ON THE DICE. I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE WHICH IS A PILOT PROJECT
ESSENTIALLY THAT WOULD. HELP THE
STATE RETHINK THE WAY WE UTILIZE
LIMITED STATE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM
DIRECTED STATE AGENCIES TO TAKE
A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN ADDRESSING
THE HOUSING CRISIS BY ORDERING
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. TO IDENTIFY AND
FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON STATE
OWNED PROPERTIES. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE BUILDS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS BY
ESTABLISHING A PILOT PROJECT.
THE LOOK AT THE EXISTING STATE
PROPERTIES THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE
BOTH ESSENTIAL STATE SERVICES
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE BILL
IDENTIFIES THREE SPECIFIC
PROPERTIES THAT ARE IN NEED OF
UPGRADES AND LARGE AND ARE LARGE
ENOUGH TO ACCOMMODATE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF HOUSING.
THE DMV FIELD OFFICES IN SANTA
MONICA CULVER CITY AND
HOLLYWOOD. HANDY THAT THEY HAND
OUT IN FRONT OF YOU A INCLUDES
AN AERIAL IEW OF THE SITES. ALL
THREE SITES TOTAL MORE THAN SIX
ACRES OF LAND A TOTAL OF OVER
FOUR FOOTBALL FIELDS.
ESSENTIALLY AND THEY ARE CLOSE
TO TRANSIT AND ARE SURROUNDED BY
OTHER COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. THE DMV FIELD
OFFICES WERE BUILT BEFORE
NINETEEN IN EACH OF THESE CASES
WERE BUILT BEFORE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THE NEWEST
BUILDING IS OVER FIFTY YEARS OLD
THESE STRUCTURES ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF UPGRADES. AND
IN ADDITION THE MPS RECENT
EFFORTS TO MOVE SERVICES ONLINE
AND DIRECT CUSTOMERS TO THE MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
KIOSKS THAT THEY'VE ESTABLISHED
STATEWIDE. MEANS THAT LARGE
UNDER UTILIZED FIELD OFFICES MAY
NOT BE NEEDED TO BEST SERVE
CALIFORNIANS. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE SIMPLY DIRECTS G. G.
F. D. G. S. IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE DMV AND THE RESPECTIVE
CITIES TO RENOVATE THE THREE DMV
FIELD OFFICES. AND INCLUDE 1100%
PORTABLE HOUSING. THE STATE WILL
LEASE THE PARCELS AT ZERO COST
TO THE DEVELOPER IN EXCHANGE THE
HOUSING DEVELOPER WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CONSTRUCTION
OF HOUSING. AND THE NEW DMV
FACILITIES THE M. B. SERVICES
MUST CONTINUE TO BE PROVIDED
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION PROCESS
AND AMPLE PARKING MUST BE BUILT
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE NEW
FACILITIES. AS THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE PROVIDES A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO RETHINK THE WAY
THAT WE UTILIZE STATE IS TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE OPPORTUNITIES
TO HOUSE PEOPLE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE SYLVIUS STROSS.
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. HELLO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA THE CITY
WOULD LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM FOR
AUTHORING THIS MEASURE ABOUT A
DECADE AGO AT THE CITY REALIZE
THE POTENTIAL OF THIS CURRENTLY
UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTY AS THE
CITY BELIEVES THAT THE DMV SITE
IN SANTA MONICA'S IDEALLY
SITUATED FOR DOUBLE HOUSE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE SITE IS VERY CLOSE
TO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF WELL
PAID JOBS IN OUR CITY IT'S TWO
BLOCKS FROM AN L. A. METRO EXPO
LINE TRAIN. STATION AND IT IS
ALSO TWO BLOCKS FROM A PUBLIC
SCHOOL. THE SITE ALSO REPRESENTS
ONE OF THE LARGEST PUBLICLY
OWNED SITES IN THE CITY THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY ACCOMMODATE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
HOUSE A NEW DMV FACILITY THAT
COULD BETTER ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF DMV CUSTOMERS TODAY
PARTICULARLY AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED A LOT OF THESE
TRANSACTIONS CAN NOW BE
PROCESSED ONLINE. THIS DEVELOPED
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS SITE
WOULD ALSO ALIGN WITH THE CITY'S
BROADER STRATEGY OF USING
PUBLICLY OWNED LAND TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SUCH AS THE
RECENT ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
UNIT PROJECT ON CITY OWNED LAND
NEAR CITY HALL. AS WELL AS
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT WILL CREATE
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY AFFORDABLE
UNITS ON THE SIDE OF A CITY
OWNED PARKING STRUCTURE. FOR THE
NEXT HOUSING ELEMENT CYCLE THE
CITY'S RENO NUMBER IS ALMOST
NINE THOUSAND UNITS 69% OF WHICH
MUST BE AFFORDABLE. THE
INNOVATIVE USE OF PUBLICLY OWNED
LAND AS PROPOSED BY THIS BILL IS
ONE WAY TO HELP THE CITY REACH
ITS HOUSING GOALS AND WE ASK FOR
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A QUICK PAUSE TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM COULD WE PLEASE HAVE A
ROLL CALL. FRIEDMAN HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE FONG. FONG HERE
BERMAN. CHEN CHENHERE DALY HERE
DALY HERE DAVIES. GIPSON GIPSON
HERE KALRA OVER HERE LEE. MEDINA
MEDINA HERE THE SYRIAN. WHEN.
WHEN HERE DONALD. WARD. WICKS.
EIGHT WE HAVE A RECORD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WE DO HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON FILE
JEREMY SMITH. OR SOMEONE REST
REPRESENTING TERM SMITH. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME TO THE TO THE TO
THE PODIUM IF YOU LIKE- TO THE
TABLE IF YOU LIKE OR TO MAKE.
THEIR WAY. I'M SURE I'M NOT
JEREMY SMITH BY MIKE MONICA
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. NOT
100% SURE WHAT JEREMY WAS GOING
TO SAY BUT- WHAT I WILL ADD IS
THAT. WE ARE OPPOSE. UNLESS
AMENDED- MISTER BLOOM HEARD THIS
TWO WEEKS AGO AND COMMITTEE- WE
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS OUR ISSUES
WHICH ARE LABOR PARTY STANDARDS
ISSUES. WITH HIM AND HIS STAFF-
HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL SO WE HOPE
THAT SOMETIME SOON WE CAN REACH
SOME AGREEMENT. AND MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. OKAY
WITH THAT OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE PLEASE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE. SIXTY
SIX. ONE SIXTY ONE IS NOW OPEN.
IN MY LINE SIXTY SIX YES SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS COMMITTEE JEFF
DON'T GO NATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS I SPENT THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES AS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED AS OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE. AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. REPLYING THE SEVEN
DAY. HELLO JANET SAID TODAY ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY THREE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BETTY DAHLE
ROLLERS WITH THE LABORS DISTRICT
COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COLLEEN TO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. BLIND TWENTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS JIM REDONDO
WITH YOU A LOCAL. OR A FOREIGN
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I AM OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTEEN HI MY NAME IS GREG
HARDEN I REPRESENT THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF ELEVATOR
CONSTRUCTORS LOCAL EIGHT AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL NOT AMENDED
THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY EIGHT.
HIGH VALUE WITH OPEN PRIVATE
CALLING ON SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE I WASN'T
ADDED TO IT EARLIER SO CAN PASS
MONEY FOR THE NEXT THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
HAPPENING THIS YEAR SO WITH
LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT AND FROST
INSULATORS AND WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION AND MUST OPPOSE I'M
SORRY I MUST AMENDED THANK YOU.
THERE IS NO WINDOW TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS OKAY I SEE
NONE I WILL JUST SAY THAT WE DO
HAVE AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE SHOULD BE THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX- I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE DMB. PROVIDES
VERY IMPORTANT SERVICES
CONSTITUENTS AND PROBABLY. OF
THAT HAS MORE FOOT TRAFFIC AND
CAR TRAFFIC THROUGH THEIR
OFFICES AND- THERE'S BEEN ANY
OTHER AGENCY- BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE
AMENDMENT TO GET THE DMV THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE- FACILITIES THAT
THEY NEED. SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS. AND WITH
THIS LEGISLATION- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES F. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- WITH RESPECT
TO THE OPPOSITION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO- WORK ON ADDRESSING.
THOSE NEEDS I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT ALL THREE OF THESE PROJECTS
OUR PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. OF
UNDER THE LABOR CODE THEY WOULD
CARRY WITH THEM PREVAILING WAGE
OF- AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE BUILT IN
BUT AS I SAID WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS THIS WITH OPPOSITION.
AND THE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. HEY WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR TO DALY SECOND FOR
MR MEDINA WE HAVE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NOT VOTING
. BERMAN. CHEN CHEN NOT VOTING.
DALY OUR DAILY AYE DAVIES GIPSON
AYE GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA I
LEE. MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN. WHEN NOT VOTING. O'DONNELL
WARD. WICKS. FIVE ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN OR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. IT SEEMS ARE YOUR
CURRY. FOR AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX
YOU MAY PROCEED. WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY.
EMOTION IN A SECOND SO WHEN YOU
TRY TO MAKE THIS QUICK BUT I
JUST DO NEED TO SAY A FEW THINGS
ON. MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
FIRST AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE OF FOR ALL
THE WORK ON THIS BILL AND I WILL
BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- AB TWENTY FOUR OH
SIX SIX TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES FROM BEING CHARGED
EXCESSIVE AND UNFAIR FEES. ALSO
KNOWN AS DETENTION AND DEMURRAGE
BY INTERMODAL MARINE EQUIPMENT
PROVIDERS. FOR REASONS OUTSIDE
THE CONTROL OF THE BUSINESS BY
CLARIFYING. AND MODERNIZING THE
PROTECTION SET BY S. B. FORTY
FIVE. SB FORTY FIVE WAS CHAPTER
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE IN A
PERFECT PROHIBITED LEVYING OF
THE CITY'S AGAINST TRUCKERS WHEN
THEY THE DELAYED PICK UP OR
RETURN OF A CONTAINER. IS NOT
WITHIN THE CONTROL OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES. HOWEVER THE
OPERATING ENVIRONMENT HAS
EVOLVED SINCE THIS LAW WAS
ADOPTED AND IT NEEDS TO BE
MODERNIZED. TODAY AN APPOINTMENT
IS REQUIRED TO ACCESS MARINE
TERMINALS WHICH IS WAS NOT THE
CASE IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE MARINE
TERMINALS HAVE BEGUNIMPOSING
RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE THESE
APPOINTMENTS BY LIMITING THE
RETURN OF EMPTY CONVICT
CONTAINERS FROM SPECIFIC
EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS. CONTROLLING
WHICH LOADED CONTAINERS CAN BE
PULLED OUT ORANGE TO ENTIRELY
LOCKING OUT INTO CONTAINERS FROM
TERMINAL FACILITIES. WHEN MARINE
TERMINALS ARE OVERLY CONGESTED
EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS OFTEN FAIL
TO ARRANGE FOR AN ALTERNATIVE
ALTERNATIVE- RETURN LOCATION
RESULTING IN CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES HAVING TO HOLD THESE
EMPTY CONTAINERS OUT THERE
FACILITIES WHICH THEN RESULTS IN
THE ACCRUAL OF LATE CHARGES.
THIS PRACTICE HAS GREATLY
IMPACTED AGRICULTURAL EXPORTERS
WERE BEEN CHARGE EXCESSIVE LATE
FEES DUE TO SHIPPING VESSELS BY
PASSING EXPERT CALLS IN OAKLAND.
LIVING EXPORTERS STUCK WITH
LOADED CONTAINERS OCCURRING A
DETENTION CHARGES FOR SHIPS THAT
ARE CANCELED OR DELAYED. AS A
RESULT ALGAL CULTURE EXPLORE
EXPORTERS ARE LOSING CUSTOMERS
AROUND THE GLOBE. IN SHORT
ABUSIVE DETENTION AND DEMURRAGE
PRACTICES WORSEN SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS BY MONETIZING DELAYS TO
THE BENEFIT OF THE QUICKENING
PROVIDERS AT THE COST OF.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS. HOWEVER I DO WANT TO
MAKE SOMETHING CLEAR TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
MET WITH THE OPPONENTS MULTIPLE
TIMES AND I AM COMMITTING TO YOU
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO ADDRESS. AS MANY OF
THOSE CONCERNS IT'S POSSIBLE
WITH RATED TESTIFIED TODAY'S
CHRISTIAN MODE ON BEHALF OF ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION.
AND ROGER IT IS SOME FROM THE
WESTERN AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AT THE CALIFORNIA
COTTON JENNER'S AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION DILLON. THANK YOU
WELCOME. THANK YOU CHAIR
FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KRISHNADAS CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX WHICH
IS SUPPORTED BY SIXTY FIVE OF
THE NATION'S LEADING SUPPLY
CHAIN ORGANIZATIONS AS STATED BY
THE AUTHOR AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX
UPDATES EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW
TO BETTER PROTECT CALIFORNIA
TRUCKERS IMPORTERS IN AG
EXPORTERS FROM UNFAIR CHIEF FEES
CHARGED BY OCEAN CARRIERS. THESE
FEES ARE KNOWN AS DETENTION AND
DEMURRAGE WHICH PENALIZE THE
LATE PICK UP OR RETURN OF
SHIPPING CONTAINERS HOWEVER
TRUCKERS IMPORTERS AND EXPORTERS
ARE OFTEN BUILD EVEN WHEN THEY
ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS MARINE
TERMINALS DUE TO THE CHIU ASIANS
OUT OF THEIR CONTROL. A WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IS SAY YOU
RENTED A CAR AND TRIED TO RETURN
IT ON A MONDAY THE RENTAL AGENCY
SAYS SORRY THE LOT IS FULL RIGHT
NOW BRING THE CAR BACK ON FRIDAY
THEN PROCEEDS TO CHARGE YOU
RENTAL FEES FOR THOSE FIVE DAYS
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY HOW DETENTION
AND DEMURRAGE WORKS TODAY. THESE
UNFAIR FEES INCREASE COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND HARM
TRADE DEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND
JOBS ACCORDING TO THE WHITE
HOUSE FACT SHEET ON THE SHIPPING
INDUSTRY OCEAN CARRIERS BILL TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
DETENTION AND DEMURRAGE OVER
JUST A THREE MONTH PERIOD LAST
YEAR IN INDUSTRY RESEARCH FOUND
THAT THESE FEES OR TWO TO TEN
TIMES HIGHER CALIFORNIA PORTS
AND OTHER PORTS WORLDWIDE.
CALIFORNIA WITH THE ADOPTION SB
FORTY FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE WHICH THIS BILL WOULD AMEND
LED THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION ON
DETENTION DEMERGER FORM THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE
THAT RENEWED STATE AND FEDERAL
EFFORTS TO REFORM DETENTION
DEMURRAGE PRACTICES ARE ALIGNED
WE LIKE TO THINK THEAUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
REPRIAND CHURN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROGER ISOM.
ON THE PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS.
THE COTTON INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION. WHICHREPRESENTS
THE TREE NOT HAULING AND
PROCESSING INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA.
OF ALMONDS WALNUTS PECANS AND
PISTACHIOS. I'M THE CARD IS
THREE EXPORTS 1100% OF THE
COTTON PRIEST IN CALIFORNIA THE
TREE DOWN THE STREET ON AVERAGE
ACROSS THE FOUR TREE NUTS
EXPORTS 70% OF ITS PRODUCTS SO
CONSEQUENCES CONSEQUENTLY THE
CRISIS AT THE PORTS OF LA LONG
BEACH AND OAKLAND HAS HAD A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
MEMBERS WE'VE HAD MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF LOST SALES REDUCED
INCOME AND THEN TO ADD INSULT TO
INJURY. INCREASED FEES IN THE
FORM OF THE TENSION DEMURRAGE.
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX WHAT
ADDRESS A PORTION OF THE ISSUE
FOR US. AND THAT IS WHEN WE
ASSESS THE DETENTION DEMURRAGE
FEES WHEN IT'S NOT OUR FAULT. WE
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED NUMEROUS
INSTANCES OF BEING ASSESSED
THESE FEES. ARE RESULTING IN
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN FEES
THAT WERE AGAIN NOT OUR FAULT
THEY WERE EITHER CANCELLATION OF
A SHIP. A DELAY OF A SHIP OR
ROLL OVER TO THE NEXT SHIP. I'M
MORE WE HAVE TO PAY THOSE FEES
WHEN IT WHEN THE LAWYERS OUR
FAULT WE COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
AND EXPECT THE FEE BUT ONE IS
NOT IT SHOULD NOT BE ASSESSED TO
US. THIS IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND WE ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE PASSAGE OF
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
HAVE ONE OPPOSITION WITNESS-
REGISTERED MIKE JACOB MISTER
JACOB YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP
TO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
MIGHT TAKE WITH PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
AND I WOULD LIKE TO START BY.
ACKNOWLEDGING AND THANKING THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US. I'M
NOT JUST ON THIS BILL BUT ON A
PANOPLY OF SUPPLY CHAIN EFFORTS
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND HAVING A
CONVERSATION- AND WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND- AND WOULD.
READILY AGREE WITH FOLKS WERE
FRUSTRATED ABOUT THE STATE OF
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN WHERE A CRISIS
IT'S UNPRECEDENTED- AND IT HAS
RESULTED IN. NUMEROUS COSTS FOR
LOTS OF PARTIES- LOTS OF LOSS OF
PRODUCTIVITY AND EFFICIENCY AND
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S BEING
EXPERIENCED IT'S A CUTE- AND
THAT IS NOT LIMITED TO CARGO
OWNERS AND SOFFICI FELT ACROSS
THE CARRIER CONTINUUM AS WELL
FOR MOTOR CARRIERS LIKE MISTER
SCHMIDT IS MEMBERS OF THE
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION BUT ALSO
FOR OCEAN CARRIERS- WITH RESPECT
OUR PRODUCTIVITY OUR EFFICIENCY-
THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU IS. IS
NOT QUITE AS SIMPLE AS- ONE
MIGHT BE LED TO BELIEVE GIVEN
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE SPACE WERE
WORKING IN- THE SCOPE AND SCALE
OF WHAT'S LIMITED UNDER CURRENT
LAW WITH RESPECT RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN MARINE TERMINALS AND
TRUCKS DISCREET. IT'S LIMITED
NATURE AND WHAT AB TWENTY FOUR
SIX IS ATTEMPTING TO DO
ESSENTIALLY IS TO EXPAND THAT.
TO MILLIONS AND TENS OF MILLIONS
OF TRANSACTIONS BETWEEN MILLIONS
OF PARTIES WORLDWIDE- IT'S A-
IT'S AN AREA OF THE LAW WHICH IS
AGAIN COMPLEX IT'S FEDERALLY
REGULATED. ALL OF THE OPERATIONS
THAT WE ARE ENGAGED IN A KERR
AND I CONTEXT OF THE FEDERAL
SHIPPING OUT WHICH IS- AS NOTED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
REGULATED BY THE FEDERAL
MARITIME COMMISSION. THOSE RULES
IN THE FRUSTRATION THAT THAN
UNDER LIGHT THIS BILL THAT WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE AND WE
AGAIN WILL BE SITTING DOWN AND
GETTING THE WORK ON THIS BILL-
HAVE LED TO CONGRESSIONAL.
REFORM LEGISLATION IN BOTH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE BEING
PASSED. THAT LEGISLATION IS
BEING WORKED OUT IN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW. AND THAT
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
NATURE OF THESE RELATIONSHIPS.
AND THAT REGARD THIS BILL IS
PREMATURE AS WELL BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE CONTRACTS
WILL LOOK LIKE HOW MANY OF THESE
ISSUES WILL BE RESOLVED. AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU NEED US STATE
OR ANOTHER LOCAL OR REGIONAL
BODY- TO MOVE INTO THOSE
CONTRACTING AREAS. BECAUSE OF
SOME AREAS OF CONCERN OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH SOME OF THE PROVISIONS BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE AS
THIS BILL MOVES FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- KURT BLACKBURN ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON- RYAN ELAINE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
THE BILL. KIND OF TWEENER US
STEVE WALKER ON BEHALF OF THE
INSTITUTE OF INTERNATIONAL
CONTAINER RESURS AND CHASSIS.
CHASSIS RESEARCH- RESIDES EXTRA
CONCERNS OF THE BILL THE APRIL
SEVENTH AMENDMENTS GO A LONG WAY
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS WE DO WANT TO LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE PROPONENTS ON ADDRESSING
SOME MINOR CAN AFFECT
COMMITMENTS FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR OH SIX. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR OH SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
MORE AUTHOR AGAIN OPERATOR
REPORT OR OPPOSITION. GIVE. THE
MANAGER WE DO HAVE SOME CALLERS
WHO'VE INDICATED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. WE WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE FORTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM KAREN MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FOUR OH SIX
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LINE. THIRTY
FIVE. STE HELLO MOM KAREN
NUMBERS- THIS IS MARK PURCELL
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A FOREIGN
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOUNDED
NINETEEN NINETEEN OUR MEMBERSHIP
IS MADE UP OF HUNDREDS OF
INTERNATIONAL SUPPLY CHAIN
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
BENEFICIAL CARGO OWNERS
IMPORTERS AND EXPORTERS AND WE
STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR OH SIX. THANK YOU. LINE
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY FOUR. YES HELLO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MYNAME IS NOT SURE
OUTLINED THE CEO THE HARBOR
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION WHEATLAND
ARE STRONG SUPPORT AS A CO
SPONSOR TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BY SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR REMEMBER MY NAME
MISSION A LARGE AND I
REPRESENTED JAMES BRADLEY
RUNNING BECAUSE ANA AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB Q. FOUR OH
THANK THANK YOU. LINE FORTY FIVE
. THANK YOU THE LITTLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU OF THE
SUPPORT TWENTY FOUR OF SIX. LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. I GET AFTERNOON
THIS IS A MARKED GROWING MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION ALSO HARBOR TEXAS
YUSHIN AND- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M SURE THERE IS NO NO TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MR MEDINA. A
QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION- I
GREW UP IN A PLACE WHERE. NEXT
TO THE PANAMA CANAL WATCH A
CONTAINER SHIPS GO BY GO THROUGH
THE PANAMA CANAL. A JOB MY HIGH
SCHOOL. AND SO FAMILIAR WITH
WITH WITH- GOODS MOVEMENT AND I
REPRESENT- RIVERSIDE WHERE A LOT
OF THE GOODS AND UP MOVING
THROUGH. SO THE QUESTION TO THE
OPPOSITION IS HOW. DO YOU
JUSTIFY ADDING ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES TO FOLKS WHO USE THOSE%
A FOR- OTHER TRANSPORTATION
WHEN- LENGTH OF TIME. IS NOT
UNDER THEIR CONTROL YES SIR IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION SO THERE'S THE
TWO FOLD- IT IS ESSENTIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A CARGO
OWNER- AND OCEAN CARRIER ANY
OTHER CARRIER FOR THAT MATTER
THERE'S A THERE'S A CONTRACT
THAT'S INVOLVED WITH RESPECT TO
BOTH THE CARRIAGE IN THE AND THE
INTERCHANGE OF THAT EQUIPMENT-
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS SPECIFY.
THE TERMS UNDER WHICH THOSE ARE
USE THEIR NEGOTIATED- THOSE ARE
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL LAW- SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT ANYONE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE ARE DONE. IN A WAY
WHICH IS IMPROPER OR THEIR OWN
FAIR THIS COMPLAINT PROCESS FOR
THAT AND PEOPLE GO THROUGH THAT
OUR MEMBERS ABIDE BY THAT- AND
HAVE BEEN FINED- AND THERE ARE
ACTIONS AGAINST THOSE FOR THESE
VERY SAME THINGS WHICH ARE BEING
COMPLAINED ABOUT HERE- I THINK
THE QUESTION FOR THIS BILL IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE WANTS
TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL LAYER. OF
STEPPING INTO THAT PROCESS AS
WELL- BUT THE BASIS FOR HOW YOU
MOVE CARGO IS A CONTRACT ON
THOSE TERMS ARE NEGOTIATED-
WHETHER OR NOT THE PARTIES FEEL
LIKE TO HAVE THE BARGAINING
POWER THAT THEY'RE OF THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR I THINK IS OBVIOUSLY
UP FOR DEBATE- BUT PEOPLE HAVE
EYES WIDE OPEN MOVING NTO THAT
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY- MOVING INTO
WHERE WE ARE AT THE PANDEMIC-
IS. WE ARE DEALING WITH
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATIONS- THEY
HAVE RESULTED IN ON PRESIDENT
NANA FINDS. DISRUPTIONS AND
THINGS WHICH WERE NOT
ANTICIPATED SO THOSE THINGS HAVE
TO WORK THEMSELVES THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. PEOPLE HAVE COMPLAINTS
NEED TO WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS
WITH SET UP UNDER FEDERAL LAW
ARE RIGHT NOW- AND THAT IS
OCCURRING- BUT THE FINES ARE NOT
A SURPRISE. TO FOLKS WHO ARE
OPERATING UNDER THE CONTRACT
WHICH OUTLINES THE FINES OR
THEY'RE UNDER A TARIFF. ON WHICH
ALREADY EXISTS AND HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY A PORT- BUT I THINK
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE'RE SITTING
RIGHT NOW. THOSE OF THOSE ARE
NOT AGAIN NOT A SURPRISE TO
ANYONE ON THE KNOW WHAT THE
TERMS ARE- THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE APPLICATION
OF THOSE THOSE ARE FAIR- AND
THEN WHO'S GOING TO BE THE
ARBITER. OF WHETHER NOT THEIR
FAIR WINNER POST. THANK YOU I
DON'T KNOW IF THE- SIDE WANTS TO
RESPOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARMENIANS QUESTION AND MISTER
JACOBS RESPONSE YOU KNOW- WE
WOULD JUST SAY THAT- SB FORTY
FIVE WAS PASSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE AND SEVENTEEN YEARS LATER
WE ARE STILL HAVING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE FAIRNESS OF DETENTION
DEMURRAGE AND SO. WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THE FINAL DISCUSSIONS ARE
PRODUCTIVE IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL ENSURE THAT-
WHATEVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DOES OR DOES NOT END UP DOING IS
ALIGNED WITH THOSE FEDERAL
EFFORTS SO I THINK THERE'S WIDE
RECOGNITION THAT A DETENTION
DEMURRAGE NEEDS- FOR THE
SCRUTINY- IN THE FAIRNESS OF
THOSE FEES- NEEDS TO BE
ASSESSED. THANK YOU. MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION- AND
ONE WHO REPRESENTS THE YOU KNOW
FOR LOS ANGELES- AND THE GOODS
MOVEMENT COMING IN AND OUT- I
THINK WE I AND I'VE BEEN WITH
AND MET WITH AND TAKEN TOURS OF
BUSINESSES OF SOMETIME THERE ARE
OUT OF THE OUT OF- ONES- CONTROL
IF A SHIP DECIDES THEY DON'T
WANT ANYMORE CAN IN CONTAINERS.
THEN THOSE COMPANIES HAVE TO
HOLD THEM AND THEY HAVE TO HOLD
THEM AND KERR THE COSTS. OF AND
NOW AND THEN TO BE PENALIZED AS
A RESULT OF THAT AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK THIS IS TRYING TO GET AT
THE CRUX. OF MAKING SURE- THAT
WHEN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
HAPPEN THAT THEY DON'T THEY'RE
NOT UNFAIRLY- PENALIZED BECAUSE
IF A SHIP REJECTED FOR WHATEVER
REASON BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY CAN. ARM THERE IS THE
BURDENS ON THE- OWNER OR WHO
OWNS THE CONTAINERS AND SOMETIME
THEY CAN SIT FOR DAYS I'M AT A
TIME UNTIL WHATEVER THEY FEEL
LIKE ASKING FOR THOSE CONTAINERS
TO BE UP TO BE BROUGHT FORTH.
AND I THINK THAT. WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS MAKING SURE THAT
THESE ARE BUSINESSES STAY
AFLOAT- BUT ALSO I HEARD THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO WORK-
AND TRYING TO FIND A MIDDLE
GROUND- SO THAT WE CAN LEAST
ADDRESS THIS NOT THINK THIS.
ADDRESS AND BRINGS THE
CONVERSATION- TO LIGHT AND SO-
AM I CORRECT IN TERMS OF THAT
MIKE. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT THE YEAH AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AS WELL- IN YOUR
YOUR EXACTLY CORRECT- WE HAVE A
CONGESTION CRISIS- AND WE DO
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE WE CANNOT
ACCEPT- BOXES THE TERMINALS ARE
FULL. A AND THERE IS A
CONSEQUENCES. AND THAT THAT IS
PHYSICALLY OCCURRING RIGHT YOU
CAN'T CHANGE LAWS OF PHYSICS-
AND IF YOU CAN ONLY ACCEPT SO
MANY BOXES WHEN YOU'RE FULL
SORRY SORRY EXACTLY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT AGAIN THE QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THOSE CONTRACTS AND
THE QUESTION OF IMPOSITION OF
FEES. AND WHOSE ARBITER OVER
THOSE QUESTIONS- SO ARE QUITE
OUR OUR ISSUE WITH THE BILL
FRANKLY IS NOT WHETHER OR NOT
THERE SHOULD BE A PROCESS FOR
RESOLVING THOSE CLAIMS- IT'S
WHAT'S THE EXTENT OF THAT A
PROCESS HOW MUCH OF IT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING AT THE STATE LEVEL HOW
MUCH DIFFERENCE SHOULD BE YOU
BEGIN TO THE FACT THAT THERE'S A
FEDERAL PROCESS FOR DETERMINING
WHAT'S REASONABLE AND FAIR. AND
THOSE WILL BE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY WELL I WANT
TO FIRST OF ALL THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE-
AND FOR ACCEPTING AMEND
AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL AND I
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND HER FOR HER
TENACIOUS NESS AND HER PASSION
ABOUT THIS ISSUE CLEARLY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT SHE KNOWS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO A LOT OF OUR
EXPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK WE ALL HAVE SYMPATHY. WITH
THE HAVOC THAT COOPER NINETEEN
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES OF
HAD ON CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND
I ALSO APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION WE'RE ALSO
OF COURSE IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS
I'M I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AT THIS POINT IS THAT
WHILE THERE'S A FEDERAL LAW
MAKING HAPPENING THAT YOU'VE THE
BILL WILL CONFORM WITH ANY
FEDERAL REGULATION SO THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE AN OUT LIAR OR
BEING IN BE IN CONFLICT AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SO I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. WE HAVE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WAS TAKE ROLL CALL. TO
PASS AS AMENDED FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN AYE CHAN CHAN I DALY.
DAVIES GIPSON GIPSON AYE KALRA
KALRA LI LI I MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN I O'DONNELL. WARD
WICKS WICKS I. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO LEVELS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU WE ARE GOING TO GO A
LITTLE OUT OF ORDER INTAKE MR
TANG BECAUSE WE DID ASK FOR
AUTHORS A LITTLE WHILE AGO AND
HE VERY KINDLY. OF CHANGE HIS
SCHEDULE AROUND TO PROVIDE US
WITH AN AUTHOR- SO WE'RE GONNA
TAKE UP AB. TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR. I AM TWENTY FOUR. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PROCEED.
ONE MOMENT I THINK YOU NEED TO
PUT THE MIKE ON BY REACHING DOWN
THERE YES THE TESTING GROUP OF
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FOUR ADDRESSES INEQUITY
IN OUR WHOLE SYSTEM. THIS WAS
FIRST BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BY
A NEW STORY IN THE BAY AREA
WHERE I SHOCKINGLY FOUND OUT IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY RESIDENT WAS
FACING A BILL OF OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE THAN 90%
AND PENALTIES. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE INDIVIDUAL HAD BEEN DRIVING
ACROSS OUR BRIDGES GETTING
NOTIFICATIONS NEVER GOT THE
NOTIFICATIONS BUT KEPT GETTING
CONTINUOUSLY FIND. THE BILL DOES
A NUMBER OF THINGS IT REQUIRES
DMV TO NOTIFY PEOPLE TO UPDATE
THEIR VEHICLE REGISTRATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'LL GET
NOTICE OF THAT WHOLE REQUIRES
RENTAL AGENCIES TO NOTIFY PEOPLE
OF THEIR ABILITY TO REGISTER THE
PLIGHT OF AGENCIES THAT THE CAP
ON THE FIND AGENCIES CAN OPPOSE.
A REQUIRES TO AGENCIES TO SET UP
A PAYMENT PLAN REQUIRES TOLL
AGENCIES TO HAVE A CASH PAYMENT
OPTIONS ESPECIALLY WE NOW RELY
ON FAST TRACK DEPEND MOST
PORTALS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
BANKED ARE THEY CAN'T GET ACCESS
TO THAT AND THEN LASTLY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALLEGE IS
OPERATE. OFF OF THE BUSINESS
HOURS THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
OUTSIDE OF NINE TO FIVE I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES HERE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE TOILET TO
SEIZE FOR ENGAGING IN THE
DISCUSSION WE HAVE ANY WORTH
WHO'S THE CHAIR OF THE BAY AREA
TOLL AUTHORITY OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL IN A RENDA AND THEN
DENNIS MILLIGAN WHOSE GENERAL
MANAGER OF. GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE
HIGHWAY TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT
DENNIS'S OF DISTRICT. IS REALLY
A MODEL I TOLD AGENCY. A FEW
MINUTES A PIECE FOR THE WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
YOUR FRIEDMAN VICE CHAIR BATES
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT IS MY
GREAT PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KINGS BILL AS HE MENTIONED I
CHEER THE BAY AREA TOLL
AUTHORITY OVER SITE COMMITTEE
THAT IN NAM PAST YEAR OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. HOWEVER I AM HERE ON
MY OWN BEHALF BECAUSE THE A
BERRYHILL THIRTY HASN'T YET
TAKEN A POSITION ON THE BILL-
BUT I AM HONORED HERE'S TODAY TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FOUR. I WANT TO
COMMEND ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH IN TO
DRAFTING THIS BILL THEY HAVE
SPENT MANY HOURS TALKING WITH
TOLL AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS CONCERNS.
WHILE ALSO TRYING TO ADVANCE THE
BILL'S COMMENDABLE GOALS WHICH I
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR AIMS TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
TOLL FACILITIES CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER.
THIS MAKES TREMENDOUS SENSE AND
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO. AT
BATTLE WE ARE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING A TOLL EQUITY PLAN
AND OUR FIRST MAJOR STEP WHICH
REDUCING OUR PENALTIES BY 80%
EARLIER THIS YEAR. WE HAVE ALSO
BEEN WORKING HARD TO HELP PEOPLE
AVOID ACCUMULATING PENALTIES.
DUE TO THE SAFETY CONCERNS
RELATED TO COVERT. CALTRANS
WISELY MADE A QUICK DECISION TO
REMOVE CASH PAYMENT PAYMENT
OPTIONS FROM THE BRIDGES.
RECOGNIZING HOW ABRUPT BROUGHT
THIS CHANGE WAS FOR MOTORISTS
WHO WERE USED TO PAYING WITH
CASH. WE SUSPENDED PENALTIES
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SHIFTED TO A SYSTEM WHERE THE
FIRST NOTICE A PERSON RECEIVES
ISN'T A VIOLATION AT ALL. IT'S
AN INVOICE AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE THIS APPROACH.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR WOULD
ALSO MANDATE PAYMENT PLANS FOR
UNPAID. PENALTIES WHILE THE
DETAILS ARE STILL BEING WORKED
OUT WE ALL AGREE WITH THE
CONCEPT OF HELPING MOTORISTS.
METER TOLL OBLIGATIONS ON A
SCHEDULE WITHIN THEIR BUDGET. IS
THE BILL CONTINUES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
COLLABORATION. WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING'S OFFICE ON
FUTURE MEMONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR HI AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. MULLIGAN AND THE
GENERAL MANAGER FOR THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT. RACES
CIRCUS IN THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
BUSINESS WITH YOU TRVELING BY A
BRIDGE OUR BUSES ARE FERRY
BOATS. WE TRANSITION THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE ALL THE CHRONIC
TOTALING OVER NINE YEARS AGO WE
DID IT IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE. IT'S BEEN VERY
VERY SUCCESSFUL WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHORS
AFTER DECEMBER TANK TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF PENALTIES ON LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND ALSO TO
STANDARDIZE PROCESSES ACROSS A
MULTITUDE OF AGENCIES THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THE SPACE. AS MORE
MORE PEOPLE TRANSITION TO ALL
ELECTRONIC TOLLING. WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IT CONTAINS
LOTS OF GREAT THINGS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BAD ANY OTHER TOLL
AGENCIES ON WORKING THROUGH SOME
MINOR ISSUES AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR SUPPORT TODAY SO THAT WE
CAN. KEEP THIS MOVING FORWARD
BECAUSE IT'S GREAT FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION NATE'S
SOLO ON THE PHONE OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE. FIND THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS TO TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR. SURE MEMBERS NEED SOUL OF
ON BEHALF OF THE- OF ORANGE
COUNTY TOLL ROADS FOR
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCIES. WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION ON THE PUBLIC UNLESS
AMENDED BUT I DID WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
CHIANG HIS STAFF COMMITTEE STAFF
IN THE SUPPORT STAKEHOLDERS. AND
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A PATH
FORWARD TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
TIME EVERYONE HAS PUT INTO
NEGOTIATING THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THE ORANGE COUNTY TOLL ROAD
SHARE SOMETHING MEMBERS CAN GOAL
OF IMPROVING THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE EXPERIENCE THAT'S WHY WE
CREATED INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES
OVER THE YEARS GIVING DRIVERS A
VARIETY OF OPTIONS TO PAY. FROM
FASTRACK ACCOUNTS FOR PAYING
WITH CASH AT RETAIL LOCATIONS
AND PROVIDING PAYMENT PLAN
OPPORTUNITIES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED COOPERATION AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHANG'S- WORK ON THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF. THE C. L.
U. ACTION OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA- WE ALL ARE IN
OPPOSITE SUPPORT IF AMENDED AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD. TO MORE
ROBUST CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
TOLL AGENCIES WITH THE AUTHOR
WHICH HAVE BEEN PRODUCTIVE TODAY
TOMORROW HOPING THAT WE CAN.
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF ALL
PAYMENT PLANS AND MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T GET CHARGE IN
ORDER TO HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING. WE LOOK FORWARD TO OKAY
LIVE THAT'S JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION WHETHER YOU SUPPORT
OR DON'T SUPPORT OR- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. ABOUT ANYBODY ELSE
WITH IN SUPPORT. OKAY ANYBODY IN
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN THE
ROOM. OKAY OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY. P. A TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND IT APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NO
ONE WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
. WELL I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
TAKING THIS ON CERTAINLY THERE'S
A LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW WHO.
ARE VERY VULNERABLE WHO ARE YOU
KNOW WE COULD SERVE BETTER THAN
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE- AGENCIES HAVE
CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOES. WORK WITH EVERYBODY- AND
WITH THAT I CAN SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION- I'M
SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE WATER JUST GOOD THANK YOU
YOUR YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
BEEN WITH US EVERY MEETING FOR
HOURS AND HOURS NOW I JUST WANT
TO THANK. THEM FOR ALL THEIR
HELP AND REALLY GETTING THE BILL
TO THIS POINT WE CONTINUE THEIR
SUPPORT AND THEIR HELP AS WE
MOVE THIS BILL ALONG SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE PROJECT.
THANK YOU AND DID I HEAR A- I
HEARD A MOTION AND A SECOND. TO
BERMAN MR FONG AGAIN WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN
HI BERMAN AYE CHAN CHAN I DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON HI GIPSON
I KALRA KALRA I LEE ME I MEDINA. THE SYRIAN. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
WARD WICKS WICKS I. TEN ZERO
ANSWER THE BILL'S OUT WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISS PETER NORRIS I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AND YOU HAVE TO BILLS AND WE'LL
START WITH AB. TWENTY FOUR
NINETY SIX. YOU HAVE A MOTION
YOU HAVE TO PUSH THE RIGHT
BUTTON THAT'S ON THE TABLE. ON
THE TABLE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO AT PRESENT AB TWO FOUR
NINE SIX WHICH PROVIDES LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WITH A MUCH NEEDED
OOL TO CURB HARMFUL NOISE
POLLUTION BY REQUIRING DRIVERS
TICKETED FOR MODIFYING THEIR
EXHAUST TO IMPLY THE NOISE OF
THEIR VEHICLE TO PROVE THAT THEY
FIXED THE MODIFICATION OR FACE A
HOLD ON THE REGISTRATION. NOISE
POLLUTION HAS BECOME A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES CONSISTENT EXPOSURE
TO NOISE CAN HAVE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS ON HUMAN HEALTH
INCLUDING STRESS ANXIETY
DEPRESSION HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
AND HEART DISEASE STUDIES HAVE
EVEN SHOWN THAT CONSISTENT
EXPOSURE TO ENVIRONMENTAL NOISE
MAY AFFECT CHILDREN'S COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT LAB VEHICLES ARE A
MAJOR AND GROWING SOURCE OF
NOISE POLLUTION IT ACCORDING TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT REYES
POLLUTION IS OFTEN CAUSED BY
VEHICLES THAT ARE INTENTIONALLY
MODIFIED TO EXCEED NOISE LIMITS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW DRIVERS
TICKETED FOR ILLEGALLY MODIFIED
EXHAUSTS CAN OPT TO PAY A FINE
RATHER THAN FIX THE MODIFICATION
WITHOUT REQUIRING DRIVERS TO FIX
THE PROBLEM LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ARE LEFT WITH OUT THE PREVENTIVE
TOOL THEY NEED TO CURB HARMFUL
NOISE POLLUTION FROM VEHICLES AB
TWO FOUR NINE SIX WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY REQUIRING
DRIVERS TICKETED FOR ILLEGALLY
MODIFIED EXHAUST TO PROVE THAT
THEY REMOVE THE MODIFICATION
WITH IN THREE MONTHS THIS WILL
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. I PLEASED TO
BE JOINED BY MARK SAVAGE FROM
STREETS FOR ALL WHO I BELIEVE IS
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE. THANK YOU.
YES WE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEPUTY IN SHARING COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARK BROOKS VISION WITH
THE POLICY ADVOCATE WITH STREETS
FOR ALL L. A. COUNTY BASED
NONPROFIT I'M SPEAKING WITH THE
PARTY EIGHTY TWO FOUR NINE SIX.
THIS BILL WILL PACK YOU TACKLE
THE ISSUE OF THE KILLER NOISE
OUR STATE. MEET THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EQUITY BILL. A LITTLE
BILL AND IT BUILDS FOR OUTDOOR
DINING COMING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. I'M GONNA FOCUS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. EFFECTIVE NOISE
AND WELL DOCUMENTED. PEOPLE
ANGRY AND IRRITABLE EFFECTIVE
NOISE HAS BEEN LINKED TO HEART
ATTACKS IN COURT OF ALL LEVELS
IT'S BIKING. OUTDOOR NOISE
CORRELATED MORE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND HOUSEHOLDS. HUMANS
ARE ALREADY GETTING SLEEP THAN
THEY EVER HAVE. IN HISTORY OF
HUMAN HISTORY. AND LOUD
OBNOXIOUS AND UNHEALTHY BEHAVIOR
NOISE THAT WAKES PEOPLE UP
DISTRICTS PACKED IN NEWBORNS ALL
RIGHT THE LITTLE QUALITY SLEEP
THAT WE GOT. EVIDENT THAT ACCESS
KORCHNOI REDUCE CHILDREN'S
LEARNING OUTCOMES. AND RESEARCH
DONE IN SWEDEN CLASSROOMS THAT
HAD HIGHER TRAFFIC NOISE.
DECREASED READING SPEED AND
LOWER ABILITY IN BASIC
MATHEMATICS. BOXLEY AND
IMPORTANTLY I MENTIONED EQUITY
STREETS FOR ALL WOULD NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL IF WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS ATTACK WAY
APPLING AN EQUITY ISSUE. WE KNOW
THAT EVERY ISSUE MENTIONED
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT INNER
CITY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR MORE
THAN ANY OTHERS WE GET OUR
HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
PROXIMITY OF HOUSING SCHOOLS AND
BUSINESSES TO BADLY DESIGNED
ARCHERY OPEN FREEWAYS. MOREOVER
THE CITY TACKLING NOISE HAD ON
LIKE KNOXVILLE EVEN LAGUNA BEACH
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CITIES THAT
ARE BEING VIOLATED AND YOU KNOW
THE PROBLEM ARE VERY EXPENSIVE.
INTENTIONALLY MODIFIED LUXURY OR
MULTIPLE CARS. THE BILL GIVE
CITY THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH
NOISE THE TOOLS TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM NOT LASTING WAY. WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THE KEEPER
SOCIETY WELL RESTED OUR CITIES
LIVABLE OUR CHILDREN HEALTHY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS WHO IS IN
OPPOSITION IS JAMES LOMBARDO.
WAS STILL IN BARTOW YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
FIND THE WITNESS THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS WERE AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY SIX. S. A PARDON ME MADAM
CHAIR THE NAME OF THE WITNESS.
JAMES LOMBARDO. IT DOES NOT
APPEAR THAT MR BOMBARD- WAS ON
THE CALL JUST ANOTHER MOMENT MR
LOMBARDO BEGINNER MY VOICE NOW
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
MADAM CHAIR DOES NOT APPEAR
THAT- THAT PERSON IS WITH US
OKAY IF YOU POPS UP WHEN WE DO
THE GENERAL TESTIMONY WILL TAKE
HIM FOR TWO MINUTES. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. OKAY OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES
BACK UP FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETY SIX. FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK. TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. SAN DIEGO
TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT. I GUESS I
CAN HURRY YES YES OKAY GREAT HI
MY NAME IS FROM A LARGE AND- I
AM. ROGER COUNTY AND I JUST
WANTED. THAT I'M- STRONG
OPPOSITION MEMBERS BECAUSE
THERE'S CITY ORDINANCES.
PRETENDING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL OF LEVELS LEVEL. THERE'S
A NUMBER. LINE FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ERIC
O'DONNELL WOOD COUNTY. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF HAYWARD IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS A STAKEHOLDER
COALITION GROUP MADE UP OF THE
CITIES OF LAGUNA BEACH
HUNTINGTON BEACH IRVINE NEWPORT
BEACH AND OCEAN SIDE ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND A FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK TO THIS BILL. IT APPEARS
THAT WE HAVE NO ONE L. TWO
WISHES TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
WANTS TO MAKE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL UP OF BEING SO HAVING
SERVED ON CITY COUNCIL FOR EIGHT
YEARS THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN IT'S NOT
THAT EASY TO CATCH A CARD THAT
GOES PAST YOU SEE IT AS A
DRIVER. BUT IT'S NOT LIKE WE
HAVE YOU KNOW OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SITTING THERE
WAITING FOR ITSELF I THINK THIS
IS GONNA BE A GREAT TOOL I
REALLY APPRECIATE I KNOW THEY
WILL- AND I'D LOVE THE HONOR OF
CO OPTING IS WELL. THANK YOU.
THE WORD. THANK YOU I AGREE I
HEAR A LOT FROM CONSTITUENTS
BOTH MY TIME A CITY COUNCIL AND
EVEN TODAY UP HERE ESPECIALLY IN
AN URBANIZED AREA ABOUT THE
INFLUENCE THAT WE'RE SEEING AND
I. AM REALLY NOT ONE THANK YOU
FOR OFFERING THIS ON THOUGHTFUL.
APPROACH TO BEING ABLE TO HELP
SOLVE THAT AS WELL WOULD LOVE BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. ANYONE
ELSE. WELL I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE IF YOU WOULD
HAVE ME I'D LOVE TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORS. THIS IS ALSO A SUB A
SOURCE OF A LOT OF OUR
COMPLAINTS. I IN MY CITY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES WELL AND- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I THINK YOU TO.
ADD AT COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A. B.
HONOR TED TO HAVE YOU ALL AS
THAT CO AUTHORS ON THE SPELLING
YOU. ADAM SHARES A JOINT AUTHOR
AND I ALSO DO WANT TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR. YOUR REALLY
HARD WORK WITH MY TEAM I MEAN
YOUR COLLABORATION ON. ON
CRAFTING THIS PROPOSAL AND WITH
THAT I'LL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE. YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NOT VOTING
. BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHAN CHEN I
DALY. DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON.
OVER LEE I MEDINA. THIS AARON.
WHEN I O'DONNELL. WARD WORN I
WICKS WICKS I. EIGHT ZERO THAT
BILL IS NOT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND YOUR NEXT
BILL IS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH ITS CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS BY
INCENTIVIZING INCREASED
PRODUCTION. AND USE A VERY LOW
TO CARBON NEUTRAL TRANSPORTATION
FUELS. DIESEL CONTINUES TO
DOMINATE THE HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR DIESEL
POWERED HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ARE
THE SINGLE LARGEST SOURCE OF
SMOG FORMING POLLUTION AND TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANTS. IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WE WORK TO BUILD OUR CLEAN
ENERGY ZERO EMISSION FUTURE WE
NEED MORE POLICY TOOLS RIGHT NOW
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND TO HELP
SUPPORT. THE DECARBONISATION OF
FUELS AB TWO SEVEN NINE SEVEN I
WILL COMPLEMENT THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD BY OFFERING
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES. THE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM HIGH CARBON
FUELS. NOW PLEASE BE JOINED BY
TWO WITNESSES JULIE ELEVEN FROM
BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND PATRICK HUNTING.
FROM THE COALITION FOR RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS THANK YOU- YOU ONLY
TO PUSH THE BUTTON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON JULIA
LEVIN WITH A BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ABOUT A HUNDRED PUBLIC
AGENCIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT ARE
CONVERTING ORGANIC WASTE TO
ENERGY TO MEET THE STATE'S
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS. WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL ACCELERATE THE PRODUCTION
AND SALE OF VERY LOW CARBON
CARBON NEGATIVE FUELS IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
MEET THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
AND I WAS THE ONE WHO PRODUCED
THE SLIDES THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
YOU AND I AND HOPEFULLY THEY
REALLY UNDERSCORE THE URGENCY OF
THESE MEASURES. WE KNOW FROM
CLIMATE SCIENCE THE BY FAR THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE IN
FACT THE ONLY THING THEY CAN
BEGIN TO COOL THE CLIMATE RIGHT
AWAY IS THE REDUCTION OF SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS. AND
CALIFORNIA THE BIGGEST SOURCES
ARE GANNETT WASTE AND BY FAR THE
MOST BENEFICIAL ALTERNATIVE TO
LANDFILLING OR OPEN BURNING THAT
WASTE IS TO CONVERT IT TO A LOW
CARBON CARBON NEGATIVE
TRANSPORTATION FUELS. PRESIDENT
BIDEN THE HEAD OF THE UNITED
NATIONS THE HEAD OF THE IPCC ALL
SAY THAT THIS IS BY FAR THE MOST
URGENT THING WE CAN DO TO
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE. THESE ARE
ALSO THE SAME MEASURES THAT CAN
PROVIDE CARBON NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS WHICH WE NEED TO REACH
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY MID
CENTURY. AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THE AIRPORT
HAS SAID THESE ARE THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE OF ALL OF THE STATE'S
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS DESPITE ALL
OF THAT THE AIRPORT IS SAID WE
ARE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET OUR
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW. SO THIS BILL IS REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
ACCELERATE NOT JUST THE USE OF
LOW CARBON A CARBON NEGATIVE
FUELS BUT FUELS THAT COULD HELP
US REDUCE METHANE BLACK CARBON
AND OTHER SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND URGED
THE COMMITTEE TO PASS IT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR NEXT WITNESS. LAUGHTER
COMMITTEE ON PATRICK CUTTING
WITH THE COALITION FOR GLOBAL
NATURAL GAS. OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
MADE UP OF CONSTRUCTION LABOR
UNIONS. OF CITIES COUNTIES
UTILITIES- AND- INDUSTRY
PARTNERS THAT PRODUCE 95% OF THE
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS. A NORTH
AMERICA. CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
WORLD LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY BUT IT
ALSO HAS BEEN THE VICTIM OF
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE- WITH
DROUGHTS WILDFIRES. CONTINUED
ABOVE AVERAGE TEMPERATURES- IN
RESPONSE TO- THE SPEAKER PRO TEM
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE CONTINUED CALL
TO WRAP UP OUR INVESTMENT
EFFORTS- INTO- MEET. OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND LOWER EMISSIONS. OF
THIS BUDGET YEAR TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL DO THIS. HELP
CALIFORNIA REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL BY INCENTIVIZING
INCREASED PRODUCTION AND USE.
THE VERY LOW TO NET NEGATIVE
CARBON FUELS- GIVEN THE STATE'S
CLIMATE- REGENCY THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES AND WE'RE PROUD TO
JOIN. THE DEPARTMENTAL GROUPS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. MEASURE THAT
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING US
REACH OUR- GOALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DO HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION JAMIE CATS ON THE
TELEPHONE OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
FIND JIMMY KATZ PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON HELLO HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMIE
COMPLEMENT ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY CALLING
INTEREST PRESS NOW I'M HERE
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION AND NONE
OF OUR COLLEAGUES FROM FOOD AND
WATER WATCH YOUR CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND IF THE- RESIDENTS TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY STOP WE'RE
ALARMS THAT WOULD DIRECT
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR A FALSE
SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S MANDATE
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL FOR THREE REASONS
FIRST BECAUSE THE FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION OF SO
CALLED NET NEGATIVE CARBON FUEL
ESPECIALLY BIO METHANE DERIVED
FROM INDUSTRIAL AGRICULTURE.
INDUSTRIAL SCALE DAIRIES POLLUTE
THE WATER AND AIR OF NEARBY
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TECHNOLOGY TO PRODUCE
FACTORY FARM GAS DOES NOT
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS THE
PRODUCTION OF FACTORY FARM GAS
REQUIRED LARGE CONCENTRATED
ANIMAL HERDS AND LIQUEFIED
MANURE. PLEASE WHICH ARE THE
MOST POLLUTING PRACTICES
INCENTIVES TO PRODUCE THIS GAS
OR ACCELERATING CONCENTRATION OF
DAIRY HERDS IN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE THE SECOND
FACTORED FORM GOT DID NOT A REAL
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS NOR DO THEY
REPRESENT ACTUAL REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THE
PRODUCTION OF FACTORY FARMED OUT
TO ONLY APPEARS CARBON NEGATIVE
BECAUSE THE LIFE CYCLE ANALYSIS
EXCLUDES BOTH UP AND DOWNSTREAM
EMISSIONS. AND IGNORES HEARD AND
WE'RE MANAGEMENT CHOICES WHICH
RESULTED IN INCREASED GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS MINUSCULES
COMBUSTED AS TRANSPORTATION FUEL
IT GENERATES BOTH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND LOCALIZED AIR
POLLUTION FINALLY THIS BILL
WOULD INCENTIVIZE THE PRODUCTION
OF AT THE TOP OF THE BRIDGE YOU
ALL WENT FUNDING SHOULD BE
INCREASED SHOULD INSTEAD BE
DIRECTED TO ACCELERATE REAL
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS WE MUST NOT
LET THIRTY THREE LEAD TO
SEEMINGLY SIMPLE SOLUTIONS BOB
ALSO WISHES. FOR THESE REASONS
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL WE'VE SPOKEN
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THIS SUPPORT THE TRANSPORTATION
TRANSITION THAT EXCEED
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS. WILL
NOT FURTHER POLLUTING COME A. B.
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS ANYONE IN THE WISHING TO TEST
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MEASURE
MEMBERS INJURY AND WE ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. VENTURA
MEMBERS RYAN KENNY FROM CLEAN
ENERGY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEDICARE MEMBERS NICOLE RICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION
HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU- OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN. NINETY SEVEN. THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH FOUR OPPOSITION
AB. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE.
NINETY TWO. BY NINETY TWO TO ONE
IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS NOT THE
BILL I WAS LOOKING FOR OUR I WAS
LOOKING FOR A. B. JUST A MOMENT
PLACE PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BONTA LINE
SIXTY EIGHT. CHRIS CHAVEZ OF
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
. BERMAN YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW
MENTION THAT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AROUND SOME THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED- YOU
KNOW ABOUT CREATING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND MAYBE-
INCENTIVIZING CERTAIN ACTIONS
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO AND ALSO-
WHETHER OR NOT THIS INVESTMENT
WITH THAT WHETHER OR NOT THE
RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT REALLY
WARRANTS- THE INVESTMENT BUT BUT
I VERY MUCH. TRUST THE AUTHOR
AND I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
WILL WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
TO WORK OUT ANY ISSUES THAT THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO- SO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN COMMITTEE
TODAY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND DAD YES I'M CERTAINLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND ADDITIVE TO
FORGE A COHERENT STRATEGY AND
DIED AND I HOPE THAT THE PATH
FORWARD THAT TAX. IF THEY CAN
CAN GET BY. ANYONE ELSE. SO I
WANT TO THANK THE OPPOSITION
PROTESTS BUYING TODAY AND
RAISING CONCERNS THESE WERE LATE
BREAKING CONCERNS FOR US WHICH
IS WHY I'M A NON RECCO TODAY-
BUT WILL SUPPORT THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD SO THAT I AND OTHERS CAN
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT IT AND
EVALUATE IT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND AS YOU YOU SAID THESE
WERE. SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY OPPOSITION WE'RE WE'RE
REYES VERY LATE IN THE PROCESS-
WE'RE CERTAINLY. COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM AND- INSURING
THAT THEY'RE NOT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WITH THE POLICIES
THAT WE ARE IMPLEMENTING. A YEAH
I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THE WORK
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
CALLS I REALLY DO THINK WE NEED
TO TAKE IN ALL OF THE ABOVE.
APPROACH I THINK ALONG SIDE
INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING TO
BUILD UP ZERO EMISSION. VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. I'VE INVESTMENTS
ARE MAKING TO INCENTIVIZE THE
ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WE NEED TO COUPLE THAT
WITH SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS THAT
FIVE WILL GET US ON THAT PATH
SO. I'M SHE ATE AT THE THAT.
QUESTIONS AND CONVERSATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH A POSITION ON THAT. AND
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
BUT- OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION. AND WE HAVE A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE. TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN AYE CHAN CHAN I DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON. KALRA
LEE LEAD NOT VOTING. MEDINA THIS
AREA. WHEN I O'DONNELL. WARD
FORD I WICKS WICKS I. EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER MOORE SAID
SHE IS NOT HERE YET SO MR BERMAN
ID LIKE TO PRESENT. TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED FOR MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED ON BEHALF OF OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY I THINK THIS IS MY
SECOND TIME PRESENTING A BILL
FOR MR MCCARTY IN A WEEK FIRST
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE THOROUGH ANALYSIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IS HAPPY
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS. CALIFORNIA IS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND LEADS THE
NATION IN SETTING AND
MAINTAINING AIR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS STANDARDS HOWEVER THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR REMAINS
THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF POLLUTION
AND GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF
TRANSITIONING TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS CRITICAL TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND STEM THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE BUT IT
WILL PUT NEW DEMANDS ON
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC GRID
ELECTRICAL GRID PLANNING IS
NECESSARY IN TIME IS NEEDED TO
UPGRADE THE GREAT CHANGE FOR IT
IS READY TO SUPPORT THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING. THESE UPGRADES
CAN TAKE YEARS CREATING A
BOTTLENECK THAT COULD DELAY
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
GOALS BY REQUIRING CARP TO SHARE
ELECTRIC FLEET DATA WITH THE
STATE'S UTILITIES SO THEY CAN
BETTER ANTICIPATE ELECTRICITY
DEMAND AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
WILL ENABLE PROACTIVE GRID
PLANNING AND KEEP CALIFORNIA ON
TRACK TOWARDS ITS AMBITIOUS ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE TARGETS. THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE STEP THAT
ALIGNS CALIFORNIA'S GRID
PLANNING PROCESS PROCESS SEES
WITH THE STATE'S IS THEY HAVE
AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS
ARE SPECIALLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND WITH ME- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR MILES MULLIN- MULLER
OR MUELLER I APOLOGIZE- BY PHONE. IN ADAM SMITH HERE IN PERSON.
THANK YOU YOU- WHO WHICH
WITNESS- IS IT THE PHONE WITNESS
FIRST SURE WHY NOT OKAY- I
OPERATE IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND
MR MILLER. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MILES MULLER
CLIMBING CLEAN ENERGY TTORNEY
AT THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. AND I'M PLEASED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED. AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
IN A CRITICAL MEASURE FOR
KEEPING CALIFORNIA ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVE ITS AIR QUALITY CLIMATE
GOAL. MIND SHARING THE
LEXICOGRAPHER CARE TO SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION OCCUPATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN BASIS GOLDEN
REGULATIONS FOR ELECTRIFYING THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR INCLUDING
THE GOVERNOR GOALS OF HAVING
1100% OF NEW CAR SALES YOUR
MISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
TO MEET THAT GOAL DEJECTED AFTER
ME THE CALIFORNIA WILL NEED
ROUGHLY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CHARGERS AND EIGHT MILLION EV'S
ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY THIRD.
HOWEVER THE KERR JUSTIN TIME
OCCUR FOR. READ UPGRADE MY
CUSTOMERS INTEGRATING LARGE
ELECTRIFICATION WOULD REQUIRE
UTILITY SERVICE. RESULT IN
DELAYS BARRIERS AND LARGER
COSTS. THEY WILL ULTIMATELY MAKE
IT DIFFICULT TO REALIZE THE
CLIMATE TRANSPORTATION GOLD.
THAT BY CALIFORNIA'S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND STATE REGULATIONS
LIKE THE ADVANCED GREEN TRUCK.
AND A VAN CLEEF WITHDRAWALS. IN
ORDER TO REPAIR THE GRID THE
ATTIC SERVE ALL THE NEW ELECTRIC
CARS AND TRUCKS COMING OVER THE
NEXT DECADE. WE NEEDA MORE
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO GRID
PLANNING AND SERVING ITS
CUSTOMERS. AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED WOULD ENABLE THIS BY
BETTER INFORMING STRATEGIC
PLANNING SO WE HAVE TO CREATE
NEED TO ACCOMMODATE WIDESPREAD
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
WHEN WE NEED IT TO MEET THE
STATE. CLIMATE AIR QUALITY IN
EQUITY GOAL. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR SUPPORTING THE
ELECTROCUTION OF MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. WHICH WILL
VOTE WHICH WILL PROVIDE MUCH
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THAT OFF
IN THE NEAR FREEWAYS PORTS RAIL
YARDS AND OTHER FACILITIES. THE
GENERATING IT AGAIN LEVELS OF
ENGINEERS OUT. SO WE MORE TWO
DECLINING INVESTMENT
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CAN BE
COST EFFECTIVE. IT'S ALL THE
PROGRESS WITH ITS- AND MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS FOR ALL UTILITY
CUSTOMERS. INSTALLING ELECTRICAL
EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO CHARGE THE
VEHICLES WILL NOT ONLY HELP THE
BIG NEEDED CLIMATE EQUITY IN OUR
QUALITY GOALS. BUT ALSO COLOR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
COULD PUT DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON
WHAT YOU'RE GRAYSON BUILD. TO
THE BENEFIT OF ALL CHARACTERS.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
FINANCING OF COMMONSENSE
PROPOSAL AND RESPECTFULLY-
DRIVER THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND YOU HAVE A WITNESS IN
PERSON ADAM SMITH. IF YOU PUSH
THE BUTTON THEN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THERE WE- JEFF IN CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- SMITH
A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
SHARING OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED. I THINK
THE PROBLEM STATEMENT THE GOALS
THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS ALL BEEN
LAID OUT VERY WELL SO I WON'T
RETREAD THAT GROUND. BUT I WILL
SAY I THINK THE STATE'S
LEADERSHIP IS HAVING REAL
RESULTS IN THIS AREA. AS PORTS
WAREHOUSES AND OTHER BUSINESSES
INCREASINGLY SWITCH TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE GRID IS READY FOR THEM.
AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOES
JUST THAT. IT WOULD ENSURE
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS LIKE
OURS CAN MEET CRITICAL GRID
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS IN
ANTICIPATION OF INCREASED
VEHICLE ELECTRIFICATION. THE
BILL WOULD HAVE CARP AS YOU'VE
HEARD SHARE FLEET DATA WITH
ENTITIES COMPLYING WITH THE
REGULATIONS WITH US THE
UTILITIES. SO THAT WE CAN PLAN
APPROPRIATELY AND READY THE
GRANT FOR THE VEHICLES THESE
COMPANIES PLAN TO PLUG INTO IT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED GETS
UTILITIES WHAT WE NEED TO PLAN
APPROPRIATELY BUT THEN ALSO
DIRECTS US TO TAKE ACTION. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE UTILITIES
WITH ANNUAL FLEET DATA ALLOWING.
US TO FORECAST AND ANTICIPATE
FUTURE ELECTRIFICATION EXPANSION
WITH GREATER CONFIDENCE. THIS
DATA WILL INFORM PLANS THAT THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES WILL
SEND TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FOR APPROVAL. AND
ONCE APPROVED WE GET TO WORK. WE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS GOOD IDEA FOR WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
PRESENTING IT TODAY. WE SUPPORT
IT AS AN IMPLEMENTING UTILITY
AND WE URGE THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION PATRICK
WELCH. AND YOU MAY COME UP TO
THE TABLE IF YOU LIKE SIR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAVE
HAD TO GO TO THE CALIFORNIA
MINISTRY TOLD THE ASSOCIATION OF
KEEP IT BRIEF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. AND THE SPONSORS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS OUR MEMBERS
AT WHICH PROVIDE ELECTRICITY
225% THE STATE ARE HARD AT WORK
HELPING TO DEPLOY EV'S WITH EVEY
REBATES. GETTING THEIR GRADE
READY EINSTEIN CHARGERS WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT THAT REQUIRES.
UTILITIES TO MAKE TIMELY
UPGRADES THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT EVEY- INFRASTRUCTURE WE
THINK THAT IS OVERLY BROAD AND
VAGUE AND CREATE SOME LEGAL
JEOPARDY AND I THINK THE
MEHMET'S ADOPTED TODAY MOVE US
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE THINK
SOME ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATIONS
ARE PROBABLY NEEDED. A TOWARDS
THAT END AND ONE THING I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE POINT OUT
UTILITIES AS WELL. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY HUGE SUPPLY CAKE. A
CHAIN CONSTRAINTS ALL OVER THE
PLACE FOR ELECTRIC INDUSTRY USED
TO TAKE THREE TO FOUR MONTHS TO
GET A TRANSFORMER NOW TAKES TWO
TO THREE YEARS AT A COST
INCREASE OF ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WORD TIMELY UPGRADES THERE ARE
THINGS ARE OUT OF CONTROL OF OUR
MEMBERS HANDS. GLOBAL ISSUES
THAT WE CANNOT CONTROL THAT WE
CANNOT FIX WE ARE URGING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ANY AUTHORITY
TO DO SO- AND WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH AUTHORED ADDRESSES
CONCERNS IN THE FOR THE FOR THE
REFINING THE LANGUAGE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATOR CAN YOU ALSO ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRS THE
MEMBERS STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HEARING THE BILL
CALLING WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOOK
FOR. THANK YOU MR BERMAN
REPRESENTING IN THE QUARTER
WORKING WITH US MEASURE FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS WE ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. OKAY OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON WHO SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. LINE NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS WILL
BRING HER PHONE OR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ANY DIFFICULT
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE A MOTION TO WE HAVE A
SECOND. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND- I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT I DO HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH CARP AND
FLEETS AND OTHER GROUPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS BILL- IS WORKABLE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY UNINTENDED
NEGATIVE- CONSEQUENCES- I ASSURE
YOU HE WILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER IS THAT YOUR CLOTHES THAT
WILL BE A CLOSE OKAY CAN WE
PLEASE HAVE A ROLL CALL. TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING. BERMAN BERMAN I
CHEN. CHEN NOT VOTING. DALY HI
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES NOT
VOTING. GIPSON KALRA. LEE THREE
I MEDINA. THE SYRIAN. WHEN NOT
VOTING O'DONNELL WARD WARD I
WICKS WICKS I. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN ZERO
TWO G. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
WE HAVE A MOTOR YOU MOTION AND A
SECOND. THIS BILL IS CONTINUING
THE THEME OF A BUILDING OUT THE
NECESSARY EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR US TO REACH NOT ONLY ARE.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE GOALS BUT ALSO
ALSO OUR CLIMATE GOALS. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT- OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CONVENIENT
RELIABLE AND EQUITABLE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS SIR DIAZ WITH CHARGEPOINT.
AND ALSO KAREN SWORE AS A WITH
THE MAKING HOPE HAPPEN
FOUNDATION. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM SO SORRY
IS SENIOR POLICY MANAGER FOR
CHARGEPOINT. FIRST YOU WANT TO
THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CG FOR
AUTHORING THIS MEASURE AND FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BENNETT PLUMAS
RIOS FOR COOPER IN THE MEASURE
AS WELL AS A COMMITTEE STAFFER
ASSISTING US IN THIS MATTER. I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE SHARE A
COMMON GOAL OF MAKING CALIFORNIA
SENSORS INTO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM A SUCCESS.
BUT IT COULD ONLY BE CALLED
SUCCESS IF EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NUMBER FROM
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE. THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. YOU
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE MUST BE
CONVENIENT RELIABLE EASY TO
OPERATE AND ACCESSIBLE IN ALL
NEIGHBORHOODS TO ALL DRIVERS
BOTH CURRENT. AND FUTURE. AB
TWENTY SEVEN OF THREE DOES TWO
IMPORTANT REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS. AND REQUIRES CC
DEVELOP RELIABILITY STANDARDS
FOR E. EVEY CHARGING STATIONS
AND CONDITIONS UPON WHICH IS THE
FUNDING COMPLIANCE WITH
RELIABILITY STANDARDS. AS A
CHARGING ECOSYSTEM EXPANDS IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE- INSURE THE
RELIABILITY OF THE STATE'S
EXISTING IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE CDC AND- RESEARCHERS BOARD
HAVE BOTH IDENTIFY EAST ASIA
ABILITIES A TOP CONCERN FOR YOU
DRIVERS. AND THE CC RECENTLY
HELD A WORKSHOP ON SUCH TOPICS
FURTHER. THIS MEASURE WILL HELP
DEVELOP RELIABILITY STANDARDS
FOR PUBLIC HE RECHARGE STATIONS
THAT WILL ENSURE THE DRIVERS
HAVE A GOOD EXPERIENCE. THE
STATE RECEIVED A RETURN ON ITS
INVESTMENT INCREASE CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE IN STATE TV
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONCE AGAIN WE
WERE SITTING SOMEWHERE
MURATSUCHI. FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL WILL AFFORD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. THE CO AUTHORS THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT. LONG
COMMUTE DRIVERS AND ADDRESSES
THE ISSUE OF YOU CHARGING
RELIABILITY. WE URGE SUPPORT
ENERGY. TO VOTE WITH THE NAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS. YES I BELIEVE
SHE'S TESTIFYING BY PHONE. OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE FIND. AS
FAR AS PLEASE.
OPERATOR WE'RE LOOKING FOR KAREN
SWARAS. MADAM CHAIR DOES NOT
APPEAR THAT WE HAVE MISSED SWORE
AS ON THE LINE LET ME SEE IF I
CAN IDENTIFY HER LINE HERE JUST
A MOMENT- AS FAR AS IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND YES WE HAVE HER HERE JUST A
MOMENT.
MISS WARS YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KAREN SORRY
THEN THE DIRECTOR OF UP LISTING
BERNARD YOU KNOW A COLLECTIVE
IMPACT PROGRAM OF THE MAKING
HOPE HAPPEN FOUNDATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ALL THE CO AUTHOR THAT AB TWO
SEVEN OH THREE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR EYEBALL ON THIS
MEASURE AB TWO SEVEN A THREE IN
ADDITION TO CREATING A
RELIABILITY STANDARDS REQUIRED
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS. IN DISADVANTAGED OR
WHAT WE CALL PRIORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS TO CHARGE THEIR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES EXISTING EVEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LESS
ACCESSIBLE FOR PRIORITY
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY IN
DECEMBER THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN ST
BERNARD YOU KNOW RESIDENTS AN
OLDER MULTI FAMILY DWELLING DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO CHARGING AND
THOSE THAT HAVE LIVED HERE FOR
GENERATIONS AND MAY OWN OR RENT
A HOME HAVE OLDER HOUSING STOCK
THAT WOULD REQUIRE COSTLY
UPDATES AND REPAIRS. AS A RESULT
INDIVIDUAL WHO ONE EVENING MUST
RELY MORE ON PUBLIC CHARGING AT
RETAIL LOCATION WELL OTHER
PROGRAMS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS FOR EASY CHARGING
THAT FINANCIALLY IT IS LIMITED
TO CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND DELIVERED ON
ONE EVEN CHARGING NETWORK THE
VITAL DIFFERENTIATOR IN THIS
BILL IS THAT THE PROGRAM WILL
MAKE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
AVAILABLE THROUGH A RELOADABLE
PAYMENT CARD THAT HAS BOTH AN
EMV CHIP AND CONTACTLESS
CAPABILITIES. THAT MEANS THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL CAN USE OF
PAYMENT CARD ANYWHERE NOT JUST
AT ONE EASY CHARGING COMPANY AT
A TIME THAT IS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM THIS MEASURE WILL
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS TO COMMUTE OUT OF OUR
CITY FOR WORK AND PROVIDE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
FEEL AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE WE
THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON. EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN A THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH THERE ANY BUT I HAVE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU CHAIRED
MEMBERS READ ADDIS ON BEHALF OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NINE OPERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE'RE GOING
TO GO FIRST TO. LINE ONE OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SANTIAGO
RODRIGUEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
. LINE. SEVENTY EIGHT. THIS IS
YOUR ALLOWED PATRICK COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSITION. WHY NO ONE
NO ONE. BACTERIUM THE AFTER THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KATHY SHAPER ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FINAL CALL
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
OKAY WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH THREE
ONE ONE OF THREE OF ONE IS OPEN. MANAGER WE HAVE NO ANNUAL TO
SIGNAL THEIR WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY. THING TO SAY. I
SEE NINE I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE I WAS
RECENTLY DOWN IN. CALEXICO AND
THE I MET WITH AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUP WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW THEY FELT THE BIGGEST
BARRIER TO THEIR RESIDENTS.
MOVING OUT OF A- INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES NTV'S WHICH
THEY VERY MUCH FAVOR BECAUSE
THEY HAVE HUGE AIR POLLUTION IN
JUST- ISSUES IS NOT THE MAN OF
THE INCENTIVES BUT RATHER THE
LACK OF CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TACKLING
THAT ISSUE. I DO HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH CARB
AND CEEC TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THAT WE'RE PROCEEDING WITH THIS
IS REALLY THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
OF HELPING WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CANAVERAL
CALL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AND- AND FOR YOUR
COMMITTEES WORK ON THIS AND-
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE. DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN
RIGHT FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE CHAN. CHAN I
DAILY. DAILY I DAVIES. DAVIES I
GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I LI LI I
MEDINA. THIS AREA. WHEN I
O'DONNELL WARD. WARD I WICKS
WICKS HI. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M BEFORE WE
MOVED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR I
DO WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT
STARTING AT OUR NEXT HEARING
WE'RE NOT GOING WE'RE ONLY GOING
TO ALLOW OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
TO BE IN PERSON WILL CONTINUE
FOR THE TIME BEING TO ALLOW
COLIN TESTIMONY FOR THE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES BUT NOT FOR
THE- PRIMARY WITNESSES IN BOTH
IN FAVOR AND IN OPPOSITION.
THEY'RE JUST MAKING THAT CLEAR
TO ANYBODY WHO'S LISTENING AND
FOR OTHER MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT
ON TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
HAVE TWELVE HIGHWAY NAME
RESOLUTIONS. ELEVEN OF WHICH ARE
FOR MEN. AND ONE IS FOR A
BRIDGE. NOW OUT. OF IT IT'S THE
INTENT OF THIS COMMITTEE TO USE
FIVE MEMORIAL HIGHWAY NAMING
PROCESS TO HONOR DECEASED
CALIFORNIANS. WHO HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SERVICE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ALSO TO
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE. NOW MOST OF THE NAME
HIGHWAYS IN CALIFORNIA ARE FOR
FALLEN PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
MOST OF WHOM ARE MALE WHICH IS
OF COURSE APPROPRIATE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR
SIGNIFICAN SERVICE AND THEIR
SACRIFICES HONORED. HOWEVER WE
DO ALLOW OTHER TYPES OF PUBLIC
SERVANTS AND OTHER TYPES OF.
AMONG REMARKABLE CALIFORNIANS TO
BE NAMED. AND THE CURRENT NAMES
THAT ARE. ON OUR HIGHWAYS DO NOT
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE AND SO. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION IN THE
UPCOMING YEAR. TO IMPROVE THE
NAMING PROCESS TO ENSURE GREATER
EQUITY. AND TO BETTER REPRESENT
CALIFORNIANS. AND I ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS THAT SAID TO CONSIDER
GREATER DIVERSITY IN THOSE OF
WHOM WE NOMINATE OURSELVES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE REFLECT THAT
DIVERSITY. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CAN WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI
FONG FONG I BERMAN BERMAN AYE
CHAN AYE CHAN AYE DALY HI DALY
AYE DAVIES. DAVIES I GIPSON.
KALRA KALRA I LEE. ME I'M MEDINA
. THIS AREA. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS I.
ELEVEN ZERO OKAY I DO WANT TO
ALSO WRITTEN FOR THE RECORD THAT
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE AND AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN WILL
READ THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS IF
ANY MEMBER HAS AN ISSUE WITH
THAT LET US KNOW NOW IF NOT WE
WILL TAKE THAT IS CONSENSUS THAT
THAT IS HOW THOSE MOTIONS WILL
READ I'M- WE'RE NOT GONNA GO
BACK TO TAKE A ROLE ON THE REST
OF THE ITEMS THE FIRST TWO ITEMS
DID NOT HAVE FIRST TWO OR THREE.
FIRST THREE ITEMS DID NOT HAVE A
MOTION OR SECOND SO ACTUALLY
WE'RE GONNA LET THE US SECRETARY
ACTUALLY TELL YOU WHICH BILLS
YOUR MOTION EXECUTIVE- I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW BUT THIS IS
EVERYBODY ELSE KNOWS- WHY DON'T
WE JUST TAKE THEM ONE BY ONE AND
LET US KNOW WHICH ONES NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. OF FILE
ITEM WANTED TWENTY FOUR. ZERO
SIX- SEE HERE I HAVE THE DEEPEST
AS AMENDED I HAVE A- VOTE TEN
ZERO. DALY DALY I DAVIES DAVIES
I. THIS AREA. O'DONNELL WARD
WARD I- VOTE. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO. HEY FILE ITEM FOR
AB. TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE. FOR
A VOTE FIVE ZERO BERMAN BERMAN I
. DAVIES DAVIES NOT VOTING. P.
THREE ME I THIS AREA. O'DONNELL
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS I. NINE
ZERO EARNED BOTH. THE BILL IS
OUT. AND THE OTHER BILLS ARE OUT
TO I DIDN'T SAY IT FILE ITEM SIX
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR WE
NEED A MOTION AND HERE'S WHERE
YOU CAN USE YOUR. SECOND OKAY
GOT THOSE DAVIS- MADE THE MOTION
OKAY. M. AS WICKS SECONDED YES.
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN AYE CHAN CHEN I DALY AYE
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA I LEE ME I MEDINA
. THIS AREA. WHEN I O'DONNELL.
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS HI.
ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT. FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY TWO WE NEED A MOTION
AND. HEY YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG NOT
VOTING. BERMAN BERMAN I CHEN
CHEN AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NOT VOTING. GIPSON
KALRA. KALRA I LEE LEE NOT
VOTING. MEDINA THIS AREA. WHEN
NOT VOTING. DONALD WARD WARD I
WICKS WICKS HI. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE NEED A
MOTION. IN THIS. WE WERE MOTION
WITH A SECOND VISIT WE WERE
MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE
OKAY DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG NO BERMAN BERMAN I CHEN
CHEN NO DALY I DALY I DAVIES
DAVIES NO GIPSON. KALRA. KALRA I
LEE. ME I MEDINA. IN THIS AREA.
WHEN. WHEN NO O'DONNELL. WARD
WARD I WICKS WICKS I. SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN FOUR WILL BE THE ROLE OF.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB. TWENTY
SEVEN ZERO ZERO FOR ABOUT SIX
ZERO. GIPSON KALRA. ALL RIGHT I
. MEDINA THE SYRIAN. O'DONNELL.
FOR VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB. TWENTY SEVEN ZERO
THREE. HEARD VOTE ELEVEN ZERO
GIPSON. MEDINA THE VARIANT.
O'DONNELL FOR ABOUT ELEVEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ZERO DALY HI DALY I.
GIPSON ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT I
MEDINA. THIS AREA. DONALD. FIRST
VOTE TEN ZERO. AND ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN FOR A
VOTE EIGHT ZERO DALY HI DALY AYE
GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I NAZARIAN.
DONALD. FOR ABOUT TEN ZERO FIVE
THE CHANGE. LEE NUMBER TO KNOW
NOT VOTING TO KNOW. TEN TEN ONE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO. DALY I DALY I. MEDINA. FOR THIS AREA. O'DONNELL.
DONALD I WORK. WARD I. THIRTEEN
ZERO VOTE. LET'S SEE YOU VOTED
ON THAT ONE YOU'RE GOOD YEAH.
SIXTEEN FILE ITEM SIXTEEN IS IN
A C. R. ONE THIRTY IT'S ON
CONSENT. YEAH I DO A. SERVICE.
IT WILL JUST SAY THAT DOUBLES
BUT I WOULD NEED TO SAY THAT BUT
WAS PULLED. RICHARD FISHER ON
ITEM TWENTY ONE IF I COULD DO-
THE VOTE CHANGE FROM YES TO NOT
VOTING. FILE ITEM. TWENTY ONE OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN.
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN YES TWENTY. OKAY FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN KALRA VOTE VOTE CHANGE YES
NOT VOTING YES TO NOT VOTING. SO
WITH THE NEW MEMBERS HAVE JUST
COMMAND WHAT IT WOULD JUST GO
DOWN THE FILE- STARTING FROM
ONE. OF THE CAN SAID I MEAN
CONSENT AND THEN AND ON THE FAR. AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN
WITH. FOLLOWS VOTE CHANGE. I
HAVE A NINE ONE. OKAY AND IT
WILL GO DOWN THE LINE RIGHT NOW.
PERFECT OKAY SO CONSENT. ITEMS
ON CONSENT. IT WILL ELEVEN ZERO
STILL GIPSON. HI GIPSON I.
MEDINA INA I. THIS AREA IN THIS
AREA I. DONALD R. DONALD I. AND. FIFTEEN ZERO VOTES FIFTEEN
ZERO SENATE FILE ITEM ONE AB.
TWENTY FOUR ZERO SIX- VOTE.
THIRTEEN ZERO. THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN I. DONALD I DON'T KNOW
O'DONNELL NO FINAL VOTE.
FOURTEEN ONE. WAS. 413-114-1401
FORTY ONE FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL NO DONALD
NO. A FINAL VOTE TEN ONE. TEN
ONE. FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR FOR VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO GIPSON. GIPSON I MEDINA.
YES AYE MEDINA I THIS AREA. THIS
AREA NOT VOTING NOT VOTING I
DON'T REMEMBER SIX FIVE NUMBER-SO O'DONNELL I. FOURTEEN ZERO
THE FOURTEENTH- THAT WAS FOR
FILE ITEM AT THAT WAS EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE THREE FOR PREVENTION
AND YOU HAVE ME AND I WAS
CONFIRM THAT. YES OKAY THANK YOU
. FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY TWO CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ZER. GIPSON GIPSON I MEDINA.
MEDINA I THIS AREA. THIS AREA
AND I WILL DONALD. MODANO NOT
VOTING. TEN ZERO FINAL VOTE
VOTES. TEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN FOUR.
GIPSON. FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
GIPSON I MEDINA. MEDINA I THIS
AREA. CORRECT. OKAY OF O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I. FOR ABOUT TEN FOR.
LEVEL TEN FOR. A FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
FOR A VOTE SEVEN ZERO. MEDINA
MEDINA I. THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I
DON'T. DONALD I. THEN ZERO.
BOATSWAIN. ZERO NO I DID NOT I
APOLOGIZE I MISSED YOU START
MISTER GIBSON GIBSON GIBSON I
PROVIDE ELEVEN ZERO. ON AB
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED THAT WAS
FOURTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB. TWENTY SEVEN ZERO THREE
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO. GIPSON. CAN. A MEDINA MEDINA I IS AREA
THE SYRIAN I DON'T. NUMBER IS
NOT VOTING MR O'DONNELL
NONVOTING. THIRTEEN ZERO. THE
GIPSON I FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO ON AB TWENTY SEVEN A THREE
. FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY SIX. CURRENT VOTE
TEN ZERO. GIPSON. GIPSON I.
MEDINA MEDINA I. THIS AREA. THE
SYRIAN I O'DONNELL. DONALD I.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX. FILE
ITEM TWENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN. HERE A. TEN ZERO.
RIGHT NOW AND THEN LET'S SEE
HERE- GIPSON. GIPSON I. VOTING
IS AREA. TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN.
THE SYRIAN I DON'T DONALD I
THIRTEEN ZERO. DID YOU MISTER
MEDINA ON TWENTY SEVEN A SEVEN.
NOPE NOT MR MEDINA I APOLOGIZE.
MR MEDINA I FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN. LEAVE US NOT
VOTING SORRY I APOLOGIZE. WHEN
WE COME BACK. WE WILL COME BACK
TO THAT ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT AT
THIRTEEN ZERO. WE HAVE WE HAVE
THIRTEEN ZERO. IS IT. THIRTY I
THINK I THINK MISTER LEAH MISTER
KALRA WERE NOT VOTING. I HAVE MR
LEE IS NOT VOTING I HAVE MISTER
KALRA IS NOT VOTING. THE.
THIRTEEN AT THE MOMENT WE HAVE
THIRTEEN ZERO AB TWENTY SEVEN A
SEVEN. OKAY FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR
. CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN. THIS
AREA AND I. FIFTEEN ZERO. DID
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL ON AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY FOUR I HAVE
AS A YES OKAY SO THAT'S FIFTEEN
ZERO ON AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
FOUR. WHEN I GO BACK TO TWELVE
FOR. MISTER NAZARIAN. WHICH WAS
TEN FOR MISTERS ERIN DID YOU.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE THE
BALLOT IN TWELVE BOOK IT IS TEN
FOR I BELIEVE IS THAT CORRECT.
I'M AGAIN SORRY. AT THE STATE
OKAY. TEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN FOUR.
AB WE HAVE EVERYBODY. THREE YEAH
THAT WAS ON CONSENT. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY THREE. TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY. TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. I HAVE YOU AS A I. ONE NINETEEN S. NINETEEN.
MISTER GIBSON HAVE YOU AS AN
ALLY. I THINK WE'VE GOT
EVERYTHING DONE SO THAT
CONCLUDES THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.